[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Vlad nous sommes là pour cette nouvelle
journée de de jeux 8e partie du match là
et comme comme on le sait Yann n'est pas
bien chier a pris un gros avantage sur
son adversaire lors de la ronde
précédente ça le cave salut la
francophonie salut tout le monde en fait
aujourd'hui les questions les plus
importantes est-ce que à l'heure Dingo
arrive encore à égaliser est-ce qu'il va
arriver à se reprendre parce que ce qui
aura vu dans les parties prescendante
j'étais pas là donc Kevin Etienne qui
ont analyse ça mais ce que on a vu dans
les parties précédemment c'est peut-être
du jeu moview de l'histoire de the shake
en fait parce que en avril
comme je sais pas dans la dernière
partie du match lascare chez lecteur
comme
je sais pas si c'était les dernières
parties je pense pas moi dans Lyon de
dernière partie du match Stains
après avoir fait une connerie pas
possible bah je sais pas j'ai pas de
parallèle historique j'ai pas de à quoi
comparer ça c'est ça a été quelque chose
de plus ou moins du jamais vu en fait
j'ai pas je me rappelle pas de de chute
comme ça parce que il y a eu des chutes
type dernière partie du match carpov
Kasparov mais c'est complètement
différent non non
cette fois-ci c'était pas du tout forcé
on a pu juste je sais pas faire les
courses qu'on appelle fainéant roi je
sais il faut 5 etc on a pu juste
continuer le parti mais au lieu de cela
il préférait de jouer HK
donc elle est réfléchi réfléchir puis
donc beaucoup plus tard et il est perdu
autant bon incroyable la shoot
émotionnelle la chute
pas que émotionnel
bon en fait je vous cache pas je suis un
petit peu un déficit des mots pour pour
décrire ce que c'est passé pendant les
parties dernière et malheureusement ça
m'a mis en mode plus ou moins pessimiste
j'ai vu que
notre ami Levan à rognan sur Twitter il
disait que oui Ding était remonté
plusieurs fois dans les dans le match
mais après des après des défaites
difficiles mais il a dit dans tel truc
normalement tu remontes pas
oui oui oui c'est vrai mais par contre
il est allé boire aujourd'hui il
faudrait qu'il gagne aujourd'hui quoi
ouais ah comme S3 surprise surprise je
m'attendais à ça depuis le début du
match
donc moi ça arrivait que lorsque
les bons pour les quatrième fois donc
resto
E3 fiche 5 ce sont les options devant A3
aussi donc
je suppose un petit roc je suppose
plutôt fou de toi
et puis important est-ce qu'il est noir
vont choisir alors l'ordre déco avec des
5 couleurs de quoi avec C5 c'est que
tout à fait de
deux univers différents on va avoir on
va voir là normalement c'est petit rock
en tout cas déjà je peux vous dire que
Ding a choisi en tant que les stratégie
pour le match de se prendre son
adversaire
avec les bancs de se prendre sur chaque
partie parce que il est pas connu pour
jouer les ninjas
il est plutôt le joueur de kapala ou je
pars
au troisième mais par jour de
l'animaisons bon il est pas gagné pour
ça donc
par contre il est clair que les vidéos
avec quelque chose une nouvelle fois et
une nouvelle fois
je suis très intrigué de prendre quoi
exactement en fait quoi s'il va pas
jouer au foot
il a fait à 3 1 à 3 d'accord
fausse 3 bosser maintenant il y a deux
lignes principales le reste c'est un
petit peu marginal soit C5
faut de 3
cavaliers
x 6 et le prochain concours il est à 5
et cetera
soit alors il y a
il y a une autre variante très
importante
beaucoup plus rare que ce que je viens
de raconter donc en fait il a joué qui
avait lieu de thèmes pour Ding donc pas
surpris oui l'idée de B6 c'est comme
dans les parties de Mokhtar aux
Olympiades contre l'équipe de
Tadjikistan faut de 3 E5 que vous voulez
E2 faut que 4 faut se bat et maintenant
les dettes des cinq fautes 4 comme quoi
le noir on gagnait des cases donc ça
l'idée d'ailleurs
c'est beaucoup plus intéressant parce
que au moins comme ça il va pas laisser
comme ça a été joué au tempo il montre
comme quoi il est prêt
intéressant parce que d'un côté si le
type joue des Sims vite c'est que ça
veut dire que il est plus ou moins
préparé par contre
pour moi c'est qu'il est aussi préparé
aussi ce qui est important c'est que
nous a précisé
et je suis tout à fait d'accord je sais
pas souvent d'accord d'ailleurs avec
cette fois-ci c'était le cas
certes tu vas prendre des lignes certes
tu as des fichiers certes tu as fait
j'ai pas une dizaine de parties
d'entraînement mais c'est pas tout à
fait ta ligne si tu viens de l'apprendre
donc il s'agit de finesse je prévois
alors E5 parce que bah parce que c'est
pour ça que tu fais des six quand vous
allez chez toi et je prévois un coup
comme 8
c'est nouveau pour moi aussi en fait
juste une question le petit module il
propose c'est 5
[Musique]
mais ok je joue je suppose soit F3 soit
encore juste 3G que beaucoup
je perds quelque chose j'oublie quelque
chose
en fait
c'est pas si facile
pour les Noirs en fait c'est hyper
complet moi je préfère les blancs là tu
me demanderais de but en blanc qui est
mieux je dirais les blancs
et pourtant tu as jamais fait dans ta
ville
[Musique]
quoi bien sûr les choses ne sont pas
évidentes rien n'est claire et donc
sinon à part de E4
quand bien sûr tu peux faire foudre 3
que les six photos
et
là je suppose le noir mon frère
et le problème des blancs une fois un
ami le fou sur deux trois
malheureusement en vie vraiment à
pousser E4 on ne peut pas parce que le
pion de 4 est en prise est-ce que tu
remarques quand même que ce que une
nouvelle fois dings débrouillée pour
avoir cette structure de pion
j'ai pas pensé à ça j'ai pas pensé à ça
au courant il est au courant dommage
bon après c'est compliqué
bien sûr est-ce qu'il y a des parties
encore dans la base
il va y avoir
36 parties pour cette position avant
cavalier 3 avant
j'ouvre pour savoir
tu dis 36 parties alors dans la base
cloud on est d'accord
ça a pas fonctionné
et après c'est 5 vlades l'heure de
vérité
16 oh
autre est-ce qu'il y a du haut niveau
tiens va gagner un contre ou le fond
d'airsson
alors ouais et sinon
[Musique]
oui c'est un beau joueur
j'ai fait deux parties je pense
je connais pas vanderstein
et ça a continué exactement comme on l'a
dit ah et là tour à deux et ben voilà
Vlad la surprise du chef rapportait
c'est bien trop profond au bon goût
ça veut dire que c'est juste faible
attends il veut peut-être tourner deux
oui oui mais ça marche madame c'est le
truc parce que tu es toujours ok pour
envoyer ce pion
janary
ok pour un bon espion d'ailleurs c'est
la ligne main
ce qui veut dire c'est juste faible
[Rires]
attends c'est peut-être que tu penses
que c'est si faible que ça cette aura
deux bah oui bien sûr ce cours
appartient pas à cette position
tu te rappelles de la dialogues fameuse
entre police lowski avec les bois
maintenant avec les Noirs au tournoi de
Zurich 53
et changer dedans tout tout début de la
partie
[Musique]
je joue selon la position
seul Cornetto s'en souvient de Sam
Mathieu ou Youtube est-ce que j'existe
encore pour toi est-ce que tu es au
courant de cette position ou pas moi
parce que moi non
alors
une nouveauté
que ce soit une nouveauté que ce soit
pas une nouveauté que ce soit une
nouveauté
qu'une seule partie pour t'aura d'eau
parce que le coup est mauvaise alors il
y a une partie de acobian
air par
mes amis thank you on est en train
d'attendre qu'est-ce qui va arriver sur
l'échiquier mais c'est un truc sur
internet il y a une autre partie de ni
unique qui a perdu
j'ai un truc à partager avec vous en
fait quand un homme Perse commence avec
Mag ça veut dire que à l'époque ces
ancêtres ont noté considéré comme les
magiciens max et magicien en fait
c'est des parties bizarres quoi il y a
John Burkey que je connaissais pas mes
comptes qui jouaient sur Internet qui a
gagné une partie avec ce tour à deux
mais je comprends rien au tour à deux en
fait c'est bien trop profond
on regarde la partie de notre côté avec
là on va pas vous la montrer
trop profonde et c'est bien trop mal
parce que normalement éloigner les
cavaliers de l'île du roi aussi loin
c'est que donc ça peut pas être trop
bien parce que le roi devient trop
sensible en fait
ah mais c'est mauvais c'est sûr
bah oui
comme comme d'hab quoi
les temps les temps passe rien de change
te proposer une autre connerie tu vois
mes amis pas tout à fait pas tout à fait
à moi perso je peux pas ça tourrado je
pouvais pas ça
le tour 1 de Brown le tour métro enfin
[Musique]
par contre
c'est quoi le problème avec E4 si tu
fais un Koh-Lanta c'est pas faux
le problème c'est fou je sens H6
à quoi c'est juste pour passer ton tour
et pas faire
[Musique]
FG quelque part et puis tout
trois points
est-ce que tu as vu comment ça s'appelle
est-ce que tu as vu
dernièrement je peux dire que moi j'ai
revu des James Bond là non je parle pas
de James Bond enfin
ça va revenir
ouais j'ai regardé dernièrement les
derniers
[Musique]
dans l'Amérique du Sud
c'est jingle
Indiana Jones chinois quoi ça faisait
comment déjà la musique de
quelque chose comme ça
ça progresse
parce que j'ai revu dernièrement les
James Bond c'est pas à me dire que c'est
un peu maudit ah ok Cambodge enfin bah
écoutez j'ai oublié déjà les dernières
fois j'ai vu ça il y a 30 ans
mais ça me touchait donc tu Rado c'est
le chariot alors de dingue OK
et ça a l'air de terrasser une histoire
en fait
très sinistre quand même
d'ailleurs en parlant de James Bond
tu as vu les Kingsman 1 2 3
à partir d'une boutique des costumes à
Londres et les meilleures questions à
Londres bon peut-être possible moi je
sais pas c'est que peut-être les
meilleurs question du monde
s'efface sur la rue qui s'appelle rose
et donc là donc il y a une boutique ou
en fait des questions mais en fait ce
n'est que le début de du réseau des
espions
c'est des petits shorts sur ce film et
je les ai pas eu pu me les recommandes
oui parce que c'est marrant
ça se moque grave de Resco
moi pour moi Kingsman 4 et le meilleur
film d'action que
j'ai pas vu encore d'ailleurs je pensais
à ça hier mais finalement je trouvais
d'autres points
oups via mon petit
je pense que ça va se finir par les
boucherie parce que faut se sac
d'habitude tu bosses pas c'est trop
dangereux parce que je viens dans les
coloriage 5 et bah vas-y devant toi
est-ce que tu as vu John Wick
j'ai trouvé que c'était très mauvais
monsieur comme quoi cela oui ok il est
comme quoi je pense soit Rosco ukrainien
qu'est-ce que j'ai à dire
de chevaux comme ça de tellement furieux
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça quoi mais
je sais que les gens adorent John Wick
mais moi j'aime pas du tout bah pas du
tout moi non plus parce que au moins à
un moment donné
j'ai besoin que ce soit au moins un
petit peu réel tu peux pas écraser 12
personnes enfin ça va quoi tu peux pas
écraser quand même j'ai pas 125 etc
bon donc ça va être H4 c'est sûr H4 100%
et puis alors déjà il se passe quoi
surprise
bah pas bien
je vois un seul coup en fait soit je
suis soit autorité
pour le public c'est dommage 5 menace
maths en un donc F6 ou F5 pour sortir le
roi et j'ai 6 dans ma fuite et merci à
vous merci au revoir donc là ce serait
plutôt un coup comme G6 admettons puis
on prend dame prend
le premier réflexe
tout de suite
dans ce cas-là respect total bien sûr
parce que c'est une ligne
dire marginale c'est rien dire
quelqu'un qui sait quoi
regarde il sait c'est sûr qu'il sait ça
peut-être sa préparation pas pour ce
match parce que Ding n'est pas gagné
pour jouer les ninjos ça peut être sa
préparation contre parce que Carcin je
pense que il a essayé ça peut-être une
deux fois quelque chose comme ça donc si
il le connaît c'est bien ma version que
alors il est préparé pour ça pour ce
match précédent
mais d'habitude
parce que figure-toi après à gérer
quoi que après j'insiste de prendre
parce que
[Musique]
des deux moi je veux pas faire tourner
par exemple
doit perdre à cause donc
et puis
quelque chose dans ce genre
de toute manière déjà un peu féliciter
les spectateurs que de nouveau encore
une fois en intention intéressante
et ça promet il est vrai il est vrai ça
promet d'être le match
pour le titre peut-être le plus
intéressant dans l'histoire en fait
Vlad le H4 est fou quoi
ça sert à quoi tour à deux mais en fait
moi on va supposition c'est que sur E4
si tu fais fouder 3
B6 je peux pas jouer E4 à cause de pion
prend cavalier prend alors toujours
avoir un fou de toi alors tu dois
temporiser si tu joues E4 direct le
problème c'est qu'il y a D5 bon c'est
ordi mais c'est comme ça
donc tu fais tour à deux pour passer ton
tour et tu prépares ta 4 parce que c'est
quand même un coup qui peut être utile
donc l'autre doit continuer par un coup
utile il fait B6 c'est normal d'accord
mais dis-moi
deux cinq c'est quoi le problème
c'est pas c'est sophistiqué non c'était
sûr que c'était un truc comme ça
donc c'est l'idée de alors rapporte
rapporte
sur internet quand même bizarre
d'envoyer ça sur internet pour une
partie c'est incroyable
je suis arrivé ici et pendant 5 jours
mon ordi n'a pas marché parce que j'ai
oublié le chargeur chez moi donc en
Afrique toute une histoire pour que je
retrouve avant pour acheter mon chargeur
pour mardi et donc je travaillais
pendant une semaine et tu sais donc j'ai
préparé en gros j'ai préparé les
fichiers pour mes élèves et chaque jour
tous les jours j'ai tombé sur les
parties de maxouglo
et de nouveau moi aujourd'hui je tombe
toujours sur les parties de Maxou
tu dois pas être bien c'est magique
c'est magique il est partout
n'importe quelle ligne intéressante
mais vous vous êtes devenu fana de
maxado pendant 10 15e pour quelle raison
parce que
à bien avant ah mais en fait ça juste un
rapport avec un seul truc je sais pas
bah je vais pas mettre la position
dentier mais en gros
Baki entamait une partie contre lui et à
un moment donné il s'est passé un truc
comme ça qui a fait un dessin
joué à 6 il a mis ce clic il a fait à 5
et il a proposé nul à Baki
[Rires]
a dit oui il doit pas être bien par hame
et du coup on est fan de lui
compréhensible
il devait pas être bien quand même
mais bon il est venu au nouvel an chez
moi il y a en 2021 il y a pas celui-là
celui d'avant il est venu ici pour le
nouvel an il a commenté avec toi non non
il a pas été bien quand Baki lui a dit
les lots de Ludwig parce qu'on avait les
bouquins d'exercice donc ok mais machin
il montre les exercices à Ludwig et pas
rames il demande toi
et apparemment
c'était trop pour parade
ah il était pas bien 1500 il était pas
bien
mais ouais il est fort il est fort
en fait c'est assez comique alors
n'importe depuis 3 ans il est appris le
répertoire avec valise E6 au lieu de sa
grande feuille de ternaire exactement et
ok je suis sûr qu'il va bien de réagir
maintenant parce que c'est un très fort
joueur oui mais j'ai complètement
complètement à l'impression que fou je
sens H6 H4 ce nouveau porno
ça existe depuis un siècle
ça en anglais j'oublie toujours le nom
exact mais le l'hameçon de la canne à
pêche ou un truc comme ça parce que
c'est la canne à pêche c'est un petit
l'hameçon là il est comme ça ça fait
comme un petit V et en fait hop ça fait
comme un petit hameçon quoi
si tu veux comparer le système de
anime
à trois fausses et puis après les bons
vise à construire le centre avec F3 4
que les jeux 3 4 avec le système
nimesovic à l'Est indien peut-être tu
peux le montrer je sais pas attends on
va attendre le couplad juste une petite
seconde
mais je sais pas si c'est vrai
oh là et moi ne pas au courant
ok mais attends j'ai compris en fait
l'idée c'est pas GF je vois que c'est
pas la première ligne de l'ordi mais
c'est F4 en fait et tu vas bien vouloir
décaler G4 et tourageux un deck groundé
le tour
ici
le cheval et puis on a quoi
parce que tu peux peut-être juste donner
et
ok je cache pas j'ai vu cette demoiselle
un peu montrer ou pas à trois
pour trois dame de 3 et après tour à
deux
H2 c'est El Janos contre
un très grand analyste
ex russe maintenant belge
il doit avoir le seum
ils disent j'ai première ligne ouais
mais F4 ça paraît tellement intéressant
comme coup pas
comment attaquer le le
dame G4 pour cavalh5
ça ça promet d'être une partie très
intéressante aujourd'hui je pense que il
y aura un résultat
soit Ding et
de nouveau en vie soit le match terminé
pour un petit poil
mais là il doit encore connaître Ding
c'est pas possible qu'ils connaissent
plus c'est juste qu'il vérifie non
pas le problème le problème de dire le
problème de dingue
si tu tapes
parce que c'est une gueule dangereuse et
donc tu analyses pas ça trop quoi après
au 4 tu analyses automatiques moi ce que
c'est les grands classiques mais
qu'est-ce que tu peux faire contre un
mec qui connaît pas les grands
classiques
dommage
on va voir F4 70 % contre 30% GF
mais il connaît pas il joue là
ça se voit
je sens donc tu es obligé dedans je
trouve dans
et puis
ah oui il y a un match
c'est juste que il est trop stressé
en fait sur son temps moi je sais plus
c'est beaucoup trop de faire ça en fait
d'ailleurs ça m'a donné l'idée
toi aussi de faire les mêmes choses
il est peut-être aller chercher une
bouteille d'eau
mais ouais ça veut dire qu'il connaît
plus
c'était l'inverse
et donc sur GEF dans F6
dame G4 qu'on regarde avec Vlad menace
peut-être cavalière 5 CD
cavaliers H5 dame 5 et moi en fait je
réfléchis à cette variante tout à
l'heure lorsqu'on parlait
dame prend et disons foude
dame
ça
ah tiens je te sur que je fais ça plus
rapidement que Ding et en fait non en
fait il est juste allé chercher de l'eau
c'est un petit peu le contraire de
ce qu'on est dans le chat
donc
GF4 Game of Thrones marche pas alors
c'est quoi les autres alternatives alors
il y a plus de
une menace très forte donc
il faut réagir assez vite et Kevin est
sur F4 comme on a parlé si les Noirs
jouent quand
dames d'accord et le noir je parle des
femmes
avec les dés de pousser F
e et cavalier E4
[Musique]
ça fait peur ce genre de truc surtout
qu'on peut peut-être améliorer avec les
Blancs oui au lieu de GF toute au lieu
de fe peut-être plus fort
ici que
maintenant donc
si alors
ça doit être plus fort que dans mon sac
je sais pas
la violence reprend les droits
je montre la ligne FG 6 sur un fuite
avec les Blancs c'est une prépa ou il
faut avoir un peu plus quand même
bah écoutez le match est en train d'être
vous mes amis
quel a été le match le meilleur
dans l'histoire avance
quel a été le meilleur match pour la
Cour européenne
ou le meilleur
tout moi je dirais
peut-être le retour de le carcraft le
deuxième pas le premier qui s'est pas
terminé mais le premier qui s'est
terminé pour moi c'est sûr que c'est le
deuxième match carpe
je sais pas peut-être pour les autres
c'est pas pareil
après je mettrai Karpov corteneuil
les gens disent car c'est naturel vous
êtes esprit vous êtes sûrs
mais pas dans le jeu
mais
il y a trop de vidéos
que c'est très fort évidemment mais ok
le foutrage d'eau premier le forfait le
machin je sais pas pour moi il y a trop
de n'importe quoi en fait bah moi je
trouve que c'est incroyable un petit peu
Vigneux il se bat contre tout en empire
soviétique et il perd les premières
parties avec toi je veux il apparaît pas
pour la deuxième partie et il gagne le
match quand même c'est quelque chose
quand même c'est une histoire j'ai pas
mythique une histoire de la mythologies
grecque tu vois incroyable quoi en
Hercule quoi je sais pas qui c'est pas
contre l'idiot contre les Titans tu vois
moi je trouve que c'est trop justement
ok maintenant les amis il est
complètement sûr que on va voir sur
l'échiquet d'âme G4 100% et puis
maintenant donc
c'est décoller 5 dame au sang qui a été
proposé par l'ordinateur
avait pas trop suivre ce que dit
l'ordinateur
d'amisif ou deux alors attention la dame
F5 direct d'un match 4 il dit que c'est
dangereux
j'ai houper
le gars il faut que tu fasses dame dame
B1 fudéen bon tu veux pas prendre la
tour à deux je veux bien le croire
j'achète
sur échec mais tu peux pas faire tous
deux parce qu'il y aura de la F5
[Musique]
et que maintenant sur damage 4 il y a
dame prend H5 parce que le fou protège
plus donc en gros il te fait fou eux
deux
il te refait dame B1 et il te refait ça
et puis
il te fait ça alors petite fait ça
espérons que ça va pas être le cas alors
alors
les
adversaires ont même temps sur le
pendule en fait chacun a une heure et 40
minutes
si c'est le cas c'est que
tout à l'heure je peux vous dire en fait
parce que je peux contacter l'un de ses
pour savoir si
une fois joué sur l'échiquier c'est plus
haut secret
avant bien sûr c'est un secret d'état
une fois joué
attends je pose une question et si je
fais E5
ok tu comptes sur cavale
quelque chose
donc comme tu comptes sur que vaillant
dans ce cas là je fais un tour Eiffel
et ça marche pas
tu vois j'avais compté sur un truc malin
ok
si je fais MAIF si je bouffe sur deux
seins disons je vois pas dans ma tête
je suppose
comment tu veux me punir ah oui j'ai
prévu
une fois je joue autour de ça que je
peux plus jouer dans mon sac
encombrer
moi je connais pas mais c'est sûr que
pote qui est là c'est l'un des meilleurs
analyses qui est là puis comment
s'appelle
qui ont entamé 70 parties ensemble
dans une partie sur le H3
et une partie sur cette variante
donc il est possible qu'en fait c'est
idiots et lick leur préparation
ah oui ils sont hyper con en fait
OK
c'est pas possible en fait ils ont dit
que toutes leurs prépas ces abrutis
excellent qu'est-ce qui sont bêtes
ah ouais ils sont vraiment je peux vous
apprendre une petite anecdote
ah mais en fait ils ont ils ont entamé
des parties avec deux comptes l'un
contre mais c'est incroyable d'être
aussi bête en fait je te raconter une
petite anecdote
ils en ont fait une vidéo YouTube sur
Youtube pour en faire pour faire des
vues
il y a même une vidéo Youtube
non mais ils sont débiles mais un lien
de la vidéo Youtube
après c'est une prépa one shot bah ouais
mais bon si tes adversaires ils ont
toutes tes prépa one shot ils vont juste
les regarder les unes après les autres
ah non il y a un 3 il y a pas de vidéo
non mais ils sont bêtes en fait ils ont
fait ça parce que c'est peut-être comme
ça que n'est pas pu savoir parce que
dans les échecs tu peux savoir ce truc
là après
pas mal mais c'est incroyable non
pourquoi ils ont fait ça
bah les réponses c'est une seule que ce
sont débiles
mais pourquoi ils entamment des parties
d'entraînement sur le litchi
c'est quoi l'intérêt en fait
ok une petite histoire mais ok c'est pas
sûr comme truc une petite histoire
ils sont vraiment cons
attends je regarde je cherche un truc
ils ont joué toujours contre le même
adversaire en fait
on va voir si ça ressemble à pas pour
championnat du monde
non ça
j'y crois pas trop à cette théorie en
fait du coup
parce que ça c'est
ils ont pu préparer ça avec les Noirs
non
plus
donc c'est une connerie c'est une
théorie de merde OK
en gros bravo le chat ça raconte
n'importe quoi
à un moment donné il se fait virer vers
le début des années 90
à un moment donné paraît-il que il a eu
des problèmes comme quoi financière en
gros il
il est cherché donc de mettre en place à
ces fichiers donc de fois et il avait
surtout peur que quelqu'un va voler ça
ouais et tu sais quoi l'anecdo dit que
quand il se déplaçait par exemple en
Dalmatie donc ouais même quand elle
était sur la plage il prenait le comment
s'appelle le petit truc là
où tu vas enregistre l'information
comment il s'appelle non
petit truc comment s'appelle
oui il a il a il a même pas laissé ça
dans ses fringues sur la plage ils
prenait ça même dans le comme il se
majeur tellement elle avait peur que
quelqu'un va voler ça
même quand
pour nager avec bah je sais pas ce que
j'ai entendu parler
avec comment s'appelle le
truc entre les mains
ouais
et puis à plus tard donc
[Musique]
cette base de données a été vendue
d'abord à Nakamura puis à 45 puis à
plusieurs autres et puis ça perdu
l'importance parce que selon les
ordinateurs modernes les fichiers de
Gary n'ont pas trop de non pas trop de
je pense le prix ça a été quelque chose
comme ça pile pour le truc
comme ça
c'est trop en fait 5000 ouais c'est ça
donne pas envie d'acheter en fait je
peux vous donner l'exemple ou par
exemple
il a pas compris avant les ordures
modernes je peux comprendre je peux
donner l'exemple
[Musique]
en fait j'ai vu le fichier
[Rires]
[Musique]
et si je me trompe pas il a choisi le
point avec fausse rentre de droite
et
c'est pas trop quoi c'est comme ça que
j'ai perdu les 24e partie du deuxième
match c'est la légendaire mais en fait
ici ce que marrant c'est que selon leur
dit H4 H5 dans la gueule c'est plus que
plus
F5 enfin tu dévorable
[Musique]
le roi adverse et puis après tu l'as pas
su
c'est trop
et ça c'était dans le truc d'ailleurs je
vous ai confié un truc à sentiment en
fait parce que peu du monde est au
courant mais ça c'était dans son truc à
5000 balles bah il y avait ma page 4
5000 balles pour ça
ok plutôt tu es au début c'était pas 5
mais peut-être au début c'était 50 000
mais puis après c'est devenu
et maintenant c'est à 15 euros sur wish
prépa du championnat du monde sur
wish.com
exclusivement pendant le parc
cinq balles
[Rires]
et avec écrit dessus si les fichiers
vous intéressent pas vous pouvez
formater et utiliser la clé USB
normalement
[Rires]
des photos de vacances de Gary quoi
et partout les
trucs quoi oui
d'ailleurs c'est sa photo c'est ma photo
préférée de guéri quand
et sa mère lui donne Star War une
serviette une serviette et il est en
train de donc se sécher avec les
serviettes et il y a
les poils sur son dos et c'est pas les
poils n'importe quoi c'est l'étoile mais
comme ça les poils
[Musique]
l'ours de Bakou
et c'est beau parce queing ça prépare
elle est vraiment pourri quoi
ok il a bien joué là alors
essayons de comprendre
maintenant alors je suppose dans ma
chambre
que je regarde
toujours Toro 2 et le pion de ces trois
alors toujours modeste toujours dans le
là il faut que je travaille
je suppose
la violence reprend le droit ou là
j'aime bien ça
ça
au lieu de deux
il joue juste
[Musique]
j'ai pas 7 dame E6
0 peut-être un autre coup là
en fait je suis hyper bien
quoi il gagnant là je pense
là maintenant comme d'habitude je
reviens à ce que Mortas dit
lion de choses que le répète toujours
l'un de ses sophisme c'est que
ce que cool dans l'attaque c'est que
dans une fois tu attaque tu peux
une photo et tu continues toujours
d'attaquer par contre calme quelqu'un se
défend une faute et c'est fini parce que
ce matin on est d'accord que Murta
serait mieux joué que toi avec les
Blancs ce genre de position bon c'est
plutôt son style c'est plutôt son stage
oui parce que ça peut être bourré quoi
il y a plus rien à comprendre si tu veux
oui c'est plutôt un bulle et moi je suis
plutôt
[Rires]
qui est mieux personne n'allait mieux là
c'est compliqué bah écoutez qui est
mieux l'action ne commençait un peu rien
dire encore mais par contre ce qu'il
faut
il faut noter noter que le prix de
chaque coup maintenant et incroyable et
incroyable parce que les sorts sont
jetés ou comment dire les sœurs sont
jetés et le conflit est grave tu penses
que le Rubicon a été passé le rubiko
n'est passé en gros Ding parti au cash
ou je sais pas comment dire et donc
chaque coup a l'importance fantastique
en fait non mais tu sais ce que ce qui
serait marrant dans ce match et si Ding
liren était Jules César
il reviendrait de la Gaule mais en ayant
bien perdu déjà
c'est la Gaule est déjà indépendante
donc le rhum avait peur de Jules César
parce que il a gagné maintenant le monde
a peur de dire parce que le pire
[Rires]
d'ailleurs je dois te dire que
la partie de avant-hier que vers la fin
j'ai pas commenté c'est vous qui ont
monté je vous essuie dans les villes en
fait ça m'a rappelé en fait de la série
télévisées
Miami
ça m'a rappelé de cette série là parce
que quand on arrête en criminel dans
cette série là
je peux me permettre de gros mots
[Musique]
je veux dire doucement ok je veux pas
dire littéralement d'habitude on arrête
un criminel dans cette série là et on
lui dit bah
j'ai le droit connard et donc d'aller
partir précédente je l'ai juste
quoi les frise pour était incapable de
faire un coup qui est dans les séries
c'est un petit peu avec d'autres mots
mais bon vous avez compris
il y a quelqu'un qui a écrit dans le
chat c'est lui c'est le Rubicon qui est
passé dessus
ah ouais
astrottoir a bien eu le rêve
que j'ai pas osé de
en français pour être sûr
alors 5 de
7 est mauvais ce qui est très très bonne
nouvelle
ça fait trop peur donc c'est Dame F5 si
tu veux pas réfléchir toujours
effrayant en fait OK et moi je monte le
jour où je sais
comment ça
alors il faut être alors
plus créatif que ça
OK
[Rires]
merci au revoir
donc dehors
demain c'est journée de repos
[Rires]
alors tu peux pas bouffer tu dois faire
égal mais bon tu vas pas rentrer
là-dedans
tu as du bol si ça ça passe
[Musique]
pour les spectateurs pour les
spectateurs
bah qu'est-ce que vous voulez
le quatrième album de Michael Jackson
et donc puis on prend cavalier prend
dame
F3
ed on va regarder ce que fait l'ordi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le premier album de Michael Subway
peut-être vous vous êtes plus au courant
que moi j'ai toujours pensé que c'est
pas son premier album
d'ailleurs comment s'appelait le premier
album de M&M
alors tu peux penser que c'est
non pas marcher Slim Shady
s'appelle j'ai déjà écouté infinite
infinite et la chanson phare du truc
c'est une finale et c'est pas terrible
[Musique]
pas possible
alors que deuxième que 3e
ni avant ni après
incroyable tu trouves
[Musique]
il a déjà 50 ans tu imagines
et les plus âgé que
n'est pas quand même il va trouver les
cours parce qu'il est fort mais il a pas
l'air bien
non mais il est assez fort pour trouver
ce qu'il faut trouver sans aucun doute
et en fait il est plus ou moins quand
même dans son élément mais sans problème
à présent
c'est que il sait très bien que en quoi
part était fini donc il faut vraiment
bien calculer bien réfléchir pour rien
oublier parce que juste en quoi pareil
tout à l'heure
il revient Ding est-ce que ce serait pas
l'heure de la pause
je suppose oui que peut-être terrain de
voir aussi pour un petit moment parce
que Dame de eux
je sais dieu seul sait même pas me
pauvre jusqu'à présent il va encore
réfléchir pendant 10 minutes et donc en
vous pour pas longtemps ne quittez pas
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs Vlad va revenir on
est de retour j'ai eu un peu un petit
bug c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu j'ai
voulu relancer directement
donc il y a eu des cinq qui a été joué
il y a eu des cinq qui a été joué et
donc on va voir comment répondre comment
répond Yann
à ce dessin
je crois qu'il vient de jouer que je
l'ai vu je l'ai vu sur la caméra mais
ouais il y a la caméra qui a buggé aussi
on va voir il y avait des gens qui
disaient que c'était peut-être une gaffe
mais je pense pas en fait parce que sur
cavalier A5 de toute façon on va pouvoir
jouer cavalier 4 pareil
et surtout rat des 8
cavalier 4 peut-être là ça change
quelque chose
peut-être là ça change quelque chose
d'un F4 F3
si on prend des 5 c'est prendre des 5 là
ça change quelques trucs ouais parce
qu'il y a dame il y a dame 3 et on
contrôle la case de c'est ça la
différence
donc tu auras des 8 il veut pas cavalier
E4 il doit vouloir plutôt tourner deux
mais est-ce que c'est dans son intérêt
d'avoir un produit ces trucs là
disons qu'elle va aller à 5 maintenant
il a peut-être des idées avec tour des
trois tours H3 qui se rajoute
mais ce sera plus avec cavalier 4
maintenant
ce truc là va être pénible ce qu'on a
perdu avec un temps avec la tour par
rapport à l'idée de base avec toi H2
mais sur des
donc surtout des 8 tours des deux
cavalier à 5 plutôt pardon il y a aussi
EDC qui est possible d'introduire
et ce qui peut vouloir un truc comme
tour D3 vous pensez 4 cavaliers H5
avec l'idée puis on prend tout rage 3
dame prend H5 maths
c'est ça sur mon son idée alors je sais
pas dans quel ordre parce qu'il y a trop
de variantes à calculer mais son idée
c'est sûrement de caler un zigzag de
tour comme ça
je suppose
je suppose que c'est pour ça qu'il a
commencé par D5 et sur cavalier à 5
direct
cavalier E4
dame F4 F3 ça change peut-être quelque
chose que le cavalier soit parti
directement en A5 à vrai dire c'est
hyper compliqué n'est-ce pas Blade ah
oui tout à fait
c'est très très dur de calculer ici
parce que à chaque fois il y a pas mal
de alternatives
dangereux dangereux
mais par contre je dois admettre que
d'habitude
il est plus ou moins dans son élément
en fait il aime bien quand le jour se
chauffe quand ça devient très concret il
est dans son plat
généralement
au niveau du temps alors
1h27 pour
dingue 1h19 pour mes pommes et on n'a
pas vu souvent dans ce match que ne pas
être moins bien autant rarement même
très rarement
on va voir on va voir ce que ça ce que
ça donne Vlad
déjà je dois dire quoi que les rives
dans cette partie quoi qu'elle arrive
dans cette partie de toute manière je
dois dire que rapporte en tant que en
cependant en tant que créateur de
nouvelles idées il est digne de d'être
du prix de nos nouvelles
parce que il en a eu beaucoup ma
quatrième partie de Jing avec les
banques quatrième fois quoi qu'il arrive
ils ont surpris donc
l'équipe russe c'est que ne pas gagner
en fait
il faut vraiment chercher des lignes
très marginales
de lire bien analyser et puis comme vent
carton
comment s'appelle ton
client
d'habitude marginale les évaluations ne
sont pas trop bons
mais donc mais c'est ça peut être
intéressant mais il faut quand même
vainqueur quand même le type
je sais de quoi ça tombe pour la rhume
c'est pas gagné je sais à quel point
c'est dur
elle est vraiment compliquée la position
déjà juste pour
comprendre mieux les positions si le
noir joue ed qu'est-ce qu'il arrive
c'est
tout à fait jouable en fait ça aussi
première réaction
on a même pas regardé le coup en fait et
c'était la ligne numéro 1 de l'ordi
bon il y a un certain logique bien sûr
parce que il veut rémuner son cavaler
sur Epson où il va être bien pour
défendre le roi alors attends maintenant
si on fait D6 on laisse le cavalier
qu'on fait cavalier 4
la main veut jouer donc c'est pas un bon
coup
je me questionne sur cette case
parce que je suis proche de réaliser
l'objectif l'ordi propose fou B7 mais
moi j'aurais pensé F3 ici si ça passe
vous prend puis on prend
les jeux 3 qui touchent comme quoi la
tour OK
ça oui mais F3 c'était pas le seul coup
donc
même si pourquoi pas d'un mois au moins
tu es sûr qu'il va pas bouffer sur 4
parce qu'il est pas mal
après tout à D8 puis on prend F5 EF bon
ok c'est gentil mais
mais pourquoi gueule ça je sais pas mais
ce sera pas le vrai B5
[Musique]
ok ça ce sera pas joué c'est impossible
parce que
comme quoi il est mieux ok ça ce sera
juste pas jouer
non donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
D6
cavalier quand même cavaler ses 6 trop
bizarre d'accord et si tu as si jamais
évidemment dame je sais et
ouais ça
fait du mal mais même là il dit que
c'est pas clair après ça ça
et ça
il est complètement taré l'ordi en fait
ok mais c'est bien trop compliqué tu
vois pas pour ça
ok supposons pas d'âme je Sète
et G4 ah j'ai 4 tu veux fous B7 et
maintenant tu menaces tu menaces quoi
d'ailleurs
bah l'idée peut-être sur fou je dos que
tu joues comme au lieu de 6 tout bête
je voulais faire ça ça et ça
et si je fais fouger deux
possible ou pas
non trouvable
donc des sisters
mais je fais d'habitude
tout de suite
ok disons tu peux essayer tour de trois
sur de trop autour de toi
attends on va revenir à quoi que tu
bouffes et tu joues tu restes
et ça se continue toujours un peu
rembobine pour voir quel point c'est
forcé donc des 6 qui relief 5 cavalier 4
disons dame D8 ça avait l'air le plus
perspectif
tourné de la savoir que j'ai aussi 17
qu'on a pas regardé
oui mon parce que j'aimerais trop penser
au pion passé j'ai toujours pensé à
matero
ok si je veux pas réfléchir
je bouffe
et je fais un coup
et je casse tous les jours avec toi de 8
parce que je force faut deux comme ça tu
auras plus de la tour sur le deuxième
4 damn D8 tordait
on leur dit plutôt dame de Madame dedam
G4 je savais pas l'avantage c'est que tu
te laisses des G4 donc c'est logique
aussi
[Musique]
j'aime bien les blancs moi
OK
[Musique]
pas de G5 à cause de cavalier F3
mais tout rage 3
mais non
c'est pas fini
de qualité turboo je5 parce que donc je
sens que
possible ok mais même ça ça continue
tu peux jouer ça avec les Blancs donc tu
bouffes pas sur je sens que tu bouffes
alors je saigne
plus facile de jouer avec les bons mais
surtout que si tu vois ça de loin tu
peux penser que c'est terminé ça ça peut
être un zéro
pas terminé mais sympa
ça peut être proche de gagnant ça ok
disons je joue en cours
oui
et puis
la main veut jouer autour de toi
c'est égal fin j'ai reçu c'est mieux
pour fin ça peut pas être mieux pour les
Noirs ça c'est impossible
bah écoutez mes amis de nouveau une
partie fantastique en fait
quoi qu'il arrive la partie fantastique
vraiment très très excitante
de quoi se féliciter
je peux montrer mais tu peux aussi
commencer par camaïeu 4 je peux vous
montrer la dernière idée géniale De Jing
de rapport vas-y je sais pas si tu le
couvrir sur ta chaîne peut-être oui je
sais pas avec les Noirs
je me rappelle plus et le jeu avec le
noir B4
[Musique]
dams
la ligne pas très bien de réputée par le
noir à 3
faubourg
je pense plutôt de décision B3
dame H4
je pars un coup comme dans deux pour
pouvoir se requin et là je sens que je
cadre
et puis il a gagné facilement parce que
l'autre n'a jamais su trouver comment se
débrouiller avec l'aile du roi parce que
il est bloqué juste il est bloqué et
puis donc on va les deux cinq grandes
roc je sens que j'ai 4 c'est les cours
ce sont les couplets pour 4 euros
j'ai presque 54 ans
mais du coup il va me manquer un tempo
pour bien faire les choses
du coup vu la complexité d'une telle
partie avoir baissé le temps à deux
heures plus une heure ça reste court
pour des parties de championnats du
monde
un peu courtes en termes de temps pour
pouvoir réfléchir
je sais pas
deux heures pour les parties ça suffit
de toute manière
si quelqu'un a la tendance de transit
quand même peu importe vous le donner
deux heures vous le donner 12 heures de
toute manière il sera avec notre parce
que il est pas à être notre parce que il
parce que il n'a pas eu assez du temps
c'est une drogue c'est une drogue c'est
une dépendance en fait vous lui donnez
deux jours pour la partie il sera avec
notre je peux vous laisser c'est
l'histoire de d'essayer de s'exciter en
fait
de retrouver l'adrénaline
ça n'a rien à voir avec assez au passé
parce que pour les atmotis jamais ça en
fait
puis on a bien vu dans les en fait ce
qui est marrant dans Championnat du
Monde et fable nous le faisait remarquer
hier c'est que c'est un champion du
monde où ça joue pas longtemps c'est
pour ça que c'est aussi cool il y a pas
de partie de 6-7h il permet il se passe
rien mais c'est pour ça que c'est cool
c'est juste avant parce que c'est plus
courtes parcours
basta elle est bien je pense pour des
parties longues ah oui tout le monde
parle
gris chouk dans le chat en fait si vous
voulez le premier
grand va être nautisme ça a été riches
qui
un joueur américain un très grand joueur
américain et
Sacha il aime bien se comparer à
richowski ce qu'il me faut marrer à
chaque fois parce que grishouk depuis
toujours depuis que il est né c'est un
joueur de chaque professionnel la
discréchevski il est travaillé dans la
banque le travail
il calculé les billets quoi tu vois donc
c'est normal pour lui ça a été normal
pour lui de transit non toujours parce
que bah il a pas travailler les
ouvertures tandis que pour Sacha c'est
pas ça il connaît très bien ses
ouvertures c'est plutôt l'indépendance
[Musique]
il est dépendant de ça
c'est l'histoire de se réveiller en fait
terrible
c'est quoi les autres c'est quand vous
êtes un manque de temps
comme par exemple vous avez que je sais
pas 3 minutes pour faire un coup
grand grand
[Musique]
il y avait tellement de choses à
calculer qu'il avait pas forcément
cavalué cet en main elle est bien elle
va faire de ça
avec quatre F3 pour les bois au lieu de
3 bah c'est une ligne éternelle c'est
une ligne très intéressante bien
évidemment
mais les bons optent pas souvent pour
cette ligne là parce qu'en fait c'est
impossible de l'analyser quoi que le
noir face peu importe quelle ligne il y
a 5 ou 6 grandes lignes impossible
d'analyser parce que à la fin du compte
l'évolution finale va être toujours le
même
ça peut être intéressant à jouer du coup
oui mais pourquoi est-ce que la optez
plutôt pour E34 et A3 5 au lieu de 3 F3
c'est l'une des lignes moi je travaille
E34 et à 5 3 c'est l'une de ligne
marginales ça n'a pas un très bon de
réputation c'est pourquoi ce site ça a
été choisi parce que
c'est plus ou moins évident que
l'adversaire s'y rapport au courant des
détails parce que les évolutions sont
assez mauvaises en fait donc c'est malin
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres coups genre
auquel on aurait pas pensé du tout
genre dame c'est un ou un truc comme ça
j'y crois pas
damsom le problème c'est qu'il y a pas
de menace
donc pas trop d'envie de faire ça alors
quand on est au 4 ou de 6 ou c'était ça
ta question
est-ce qu'il y a un autre coup quoi
je sais pas
peut-être je vais dire une connerie mais
tour de dos alors
pour un jour transférer la tour sur H3
sur H3 par D3
ça peut être une option ça
oui je joue
ça peut être une réaction ça et à part
de tour de deux je vois pas d'autres
opérations en fait je vois pas d'autres
cours il y en a pas
en fait
pour du bien ou pour du mal
moi je suppose que peut-être
l'une des raisons de choisir cette ligne
par l'équipe Ding aujourd'hui ça a été
peut-être que analysant les parties de
dépôt ils sont venus à la conclusion que
peut-être nepo est un peu fragile
lorsqu'il s'agit de défendre son droit
peut-être c'est une version
de toute manière
je fais l'entraîneur depuis six ans donc
ça veut dire que je suis toutes les
parties pour mes élèves je regarde
toutes les parties du haut niveau et
la conclusion que moi c'est que
la phase de défense de la défense du roi
et l'élément le plus fragile chez tous
les jours y compris Carson juste tous
les joueurs gaffe dans cette phase du
jour en fait sinon par exemple
demi-finale fort probable que personne
va juste jouer mieux que l'ordinateur
plus moment que l'ordinateur
calcul
on parlait pendant des heures mais la
défense tout le monde
tout le monde a fait un moment donné
c'est drôle l'élément du jour le plus le
plus dur en fait
pourquoi parce que
comment ça peut musical musical
l'enfant tombe de l'Opéra vous vous êtes
en train de voir les fantômes vous êtes
en train de voir les ombres des fantômes
qui ne sont pas là à votre vous êtes en
train de crier vous-même les dangers qui
parfois n'existent pas en fait
le chat avait raison c'était bien la
préparation de Ding sur le chat bah
envoyer une preuve
d'envoyer des preuves en fait
ce que j'ai vu
ça a pas l'air convaincant en fait c'est
un petit peu comme l'épreuve que fichier
abattu pour du monde il y a 20 ans sur
ICC en jouant F3 ou F2
à l'époque je me rappelais que il y
avait même des articles dans la presse
comme
je pense qu'il y avait un article de
hommage au short qu'on retient un
Fischer revenu
après Hikaru il a aussi dit qu'il avait
des preuves que neiman tricher plus ou
moins quoi
aussi 100%
tu peux pas savoir mais les parties
qu'on a vu rapidement avec Vlad c'était
dans le Répert c'était pas dans le dans
un répertoire possible en fait
non mais c'est déjà d'une telle qualité
que je peux pas moi jeunesse
de partir d'entraînement avec quelqu'un
aussi nul que ça
[Musique]
des parties avec des comptes anonymes
trop bizarre
tu peux jamais savoir ça ressemble à
rien les parties qu'on a vu juste à rien
[Musique]
vu
il y a d'autres choses il y avait il y
avait des berlinoises que Ding aurait ni
plus entamer avec les blancs ni avec les
noirs
donc
c'est les ouvertures qu'il a joué
pourquoi ils entament des parties qui
ont aucun rapport avec lui
il y a des profs avec F3 Roy F2 alors
maintenant on sait que c'est juste
quelqu'un qui triché en fait mais alors
où est-ce qu'on peut retrouver cette
information je sais pas mais c'était
juste un mec qui triche avec l'ordi
non je suis Bobby Fisher les gens l'ont
cru et du coup il a pu continuer à
tricher
c'est trop déjà
parce que Fischer
les joueurs de chèque par contre les
cagnots pour respecter les échecs
oui donc je le vois très mal de
commencer avec trois au F2 c'est pas
afficheresse
pour brouiller les pistes qu'ils ont
fait des parties non mais les gars il y
a 70 parties entre deux comptes il
brouillent les pistes de quoi en fait tu
brûles quelle piste enfin c'est juste
idiot en fait c'est mais c'est
incroyable mais bon c'est comme
d'habitude c'est ce qui va marcher en
fait c'est pas la partie d'échec qui va
marcher c'est la rumeur à la con
personne sait on verra il demandera en
conférence de presse et on verra bien
on n'en sait rien en fait il brouille
les pistes
peut-être oui peut-être non c'est pas en
fait
d'ailleurs parlant de Fisher j'ai appris
un truc assez marrant
il y a un ex très fort joueur de l'élite
qui s'appelle blasting
donc ici vous voulez en 93 il a visité
ce cher à Budapest
bien sûr ils se sont retrouvés dans un
des bancs ancienne turc qui s'appelle
galert c'est tout au centre de la ville
j'ai pas été mais j'ai vu les photos
de ce qui est intérieur et
c'était pour raconter quoi
je le raconte
[Musique]
gris dans les bains dans les
ah oui oui oui et après faire les bandes
j'ai un bon coin où elle est et donc
elles étaient allées de bouffer les
sushis donc le grand il a dit que c'est
son hôtel les meilleurs ou sushi qui est
la jamais bouffer ni avant ni après
c'était jamais donné mon qualité et puis
donc il faut payer et donc monsieur
japonais apporte l'édition et c'est
juste les les les
pure pas cher et pourquoi parce que un
peu plus tard après avoir amené les
édition il est rémuné les les postes
pour que les autographes parce que
fichiers en fait pendant des années et
les pays se soucher avec ses autographes
en fait et symboliquement elle est payé
j'ai pas 3 euros mais sinon il est payé
avec les autographes en fait
c'est pratique pas mal pas mal
je pense que un jour ça va arriver
pas à moi moi toi oui
possible je sais pas ici on avait le
plan tout à l'heure là ça paraît un peu
moins mais
je pense à F4 dans
échecs
moi si je me trompe pas non
donc il y a pas
vous avez oublié cette tour en deux bien
placé pour leur donne grande mais mal
placé pour le dame CE1
toi
malheureusement non quoi
que ce soit des
deux je pense qu'il bouge comme moi
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça à chaque fois
de réfléchir comment
il dit Oh quoi pendant l'éternité mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça quoi de toute
façon tu vas pas comprendre si c'est
mieux de tour des deux ou des 6 non oui
mais vas-y bouge
parce que je suis imbécile et je veux
garder l'option de communication pour
plus tard parce que je suis imbécile
dans ma vie
toi tour de 2 mais comme je vois pas
trop de perspective pour le pion sur de
5 je bouge j'attends les réponses et
après je réfléchis voilà et je garde
l'option de colocataire pour le futur
en France mille fois plus en France
grâce
à ce mec avant pas du tout est-ce que
des gens te connaissent en Russie bah
pas du tout en fait en fait le truc
c'est que les Russes savent pas que
j'habite à Bruxelles et j'étais jamais
joueuse d'ailleurs et en fait à chaque
fois que je passe j'ai pas quelque part
enceinte je tombe sur un joueur de cette
action voilà tu viens de te réveiller de
France bah non j'habite ici en fait
bah c'est parce que toi pas trop les
milieux
j'ai pas trois quatre mecs pas plus
personne n'est au courant que je suis
là-bas en fait
enfin
étranger quoi
j'habite à Moscou
mais je pense que qui a pour me conduire
tu as un petit peu moins utile
c'est à 100% sûr que tu aurais fait des
trucs c'est bien trop je sais pas
envie
[Musique]
de après je sais pas
à un moment donné il y avait de beau qui
est passé par mon appartement
et donc on a parlé de rien et puis donc
à notre chaîne les questions des joueurs
chinois et m'a montré sa partie contre
Ding avec les banques elle a perdu il y
a peut-être quelque chose comme ça
c'était incroyable à partir d'un moment
donné
[Musique]
je vous adresse à regarder cette partie
de Bob Ding j'en ai en 2013 ou 2014 2014
de beauf avec les bons
quelque chose donc depuis peut-être
peut-être j'ai une faiblesse peut-être
je l'ai tendance de un petit peu
parce que là ça a pas l'air d'être hyper
impressionnant pour le moment on a envie
qu'il joue un peu plus vite
il va se refoudre avec 5 minutes pour
32e
parce que c'est en ce moment où la
précis que j'ai mangé de la glace
je vais sortir
oh là là et vous vous étiez en train de
crier au dos avec bac
moi j'ai tout de suite senti non qu'il
allait
mis plus de temps à comprendre ça moi
j'ai compris vite que
en fait je pense que Pâques il a pas pu
penser que c'était même possible
est-ce que tu te gênais souvent dans ta
vie ouais moi ça m'est arrivé de faire
ça et ça a été plus ou moins dans quelle
situation un peu la même que lui quoi
bonne partie tu domines tu as pas encore
gagné tu sais pas pourquoi et tout d'un
coup tu
et voilà
bah je dois dire que moi je me suis je
l'ai que
enfin je me suis gelé dans les
situations complètement différentes ça a
été quand j'ai attaqué les filles
et puis donc j'ai préparé une deux trois
phrases
attaquante on appelle ça draguer ok
draguer mais je préfère attaquer
d'ailleurs je lui dis à l'exprime je
connais le mode raye et puis donc les
réponses inattendues les réponses
inattendues auxquelles je me je t'ai pas
préparé et puis oh je l'ai je l'ai rien
à dire
de nouveau je suis dans la merde
ça m'arrive là ça se voit
beaucoup moins que avec les filles et
quand les mecs ont attaqué ton droit
non beaucoup moins qu'avec les filles
non les filles il y a rien de plus
sinistres que les filles qui te répond
des trucs inattendus
comment quelqu'un qui te propose le
verbe assaillir
ma paquet moi d'ailleurs
par exemple
mon pote André chicachev il vit très
proche de les rapports Charles de Gaulle
et puis à un moment donné donc elle
était trop en train de passer un bon
soirée oui qui fait donc
accompagné à l'aéroport et puis à ma vie
une compagnie des filles mais vraiment
impressionnante
moi j'ai pas osé André a essayé de
assaillir et puis les filles donc
répondent d'une manière inattendue
[Musique]
c'est vraiment trop hein
il va avoir perdu tout son temps et il
va vraiment refaire comme avant-hier
est-ce qu'il t'amuse
[Rires]
c'est dans Batman
il a un truc pour frise les gens
je pense c'est Batman
[Rires]
[Musique]
je pense que je vois à quoi il ressemble
attends pour le moment j'ai pas mais je
vais bientôt avoir
rien que sa gueule me frise déjà ouais
je vois pas ça dans mes cauchemars
là il a joué des six ah bien bien bien
bien ok il a dépensé rendre
20 minutes pour faire ce cours par
contre ce que bien le reste c'est facile
OK si vous voulez
mes pronostics je donne 50% qu'il gagne
25% nul 25%
Lumia il faut que je réfléchisse
bien sûr ça dépend de l'état ça dépend
de les situations ça dépend de ma forme
j'aurais dit 2004 25
parce que moi
et je pense que c'est en décembre de te
poser cette question parce que
moi je suis de Marseille donc vous
pouvez me poser n'importe quelle
question
là je suis Non classé
retraité
bon sur une autre
il y a rien de quoi réfléchir sur une
autre perd du temps enfin en fait il
fait n'importe quoi
il est pas resté assis il est trop
stressé en fait il panique trop pas trop
pratique en fait je pense que la partie
précédente a quand même laissé quelques
traces
et on sait très bien de quel type de
trace ça parle Vlade
non mission non tu te trompes que le
cadre est maintenant à danse
alors
la partie elle est terminée regardez
à moins qu'il ait soif
non avec toi en a parlé de G4 il faut
bosser faut
judo je suppose par contre il est vrai
que il y a une hauteur alternative
manuel la main veut aussi faire 1 2 3
pour si jamais menacé gagné une partie
en jouant dans monstre
je sais et maintenant je craque un mec
j'ai défendu le cavalier le 4 donc tu as
plus de photos
[Musique]
oui donc ouais je sais je suppose ok je
fonce 4
maintenant
si tu bouge ton cavalier sur
si tu joues
je suppose
pas non plus de comment les jeux de pour
les mêmes raisons
alors donc dans deux trois rois je sais
que G4
si corollages 6
je sais pas j'ai 5 là
j'ai notre
propositions sur l'échiquier
bien joué
donc
puis on prend
F6 et ça va oui mais il est cool
de 113 les intouchables où je me suis
trompé
il a dû avoir quelque chose comme ça ou
un titre
entamer un coup comme tour des deux
peut-être ou de cette fin
attends d'ailleurs
pour vous les chaînes spectateurs il y
avait un article fantastique écrit par
Edmar Menis en grand terme ça a été un
livre sur les parties
perdues
et j'ai bien aimé les règles dans les
finales les premières règles de les
finales
définies par donc l'auteur Edmar
ministre les pions passés doivent être
poussés
sont de dangereux criminels qui doivent
être mis sous verrous
Ding réfléchit maintenant parce que ça
gestion du temps est catastrophique en
fait il a déjà perdu une partie à cause
de ça il va peut-être en perdre une
deuxième mais aussi poscule de votre
calculer d'armes je sais dame de 8
en fait
je suis d'accord et ça a été maintenant
je suis d'accord
en fait un moment donné tu peux pas tout
contrôler
tu peux pas contrôler ma destiné c'est
pas la peine c'est pas
qu'est-ce que je chante
[Musique]
de gains à Digne je crois que tu es
optimiste
non non je je reste toujours optimiste
parce que là il tente sévèrement
[Rires]
grotte Escada
le pire le pire si il va dépendre trop
de temps et de nouveau perdre à cause du
temps le pire c'est pas qu'il va perdre
le match le pire c'est qu'il va jamais
oublier ça danse
pourquoi j'ai réfléchi autant mais
pourquoi j'ai toujours la tendance de me
gêner
ah mais là ça ça peut laisser des traces
dans le cale but quoi
[Musique]
en train d'arriver ça va être l'heure de
la deuxième pause on doit faire plus de
pause aujourd'hui on a le nouveau
partenaire vous avez peut-être pu voir
la petite publicité c'est peut-être le
moment de faire une pause Vlad
oui peut-être le moment notre arrivée ma
place c'est la pause
sinon donc un grand choix entre G4 dame
de trois
peut-être retour dedans
sinon le reste plus ou moins allemand
tu veux justifier
d'une manière ou l'autre maniaque
pas pour rien car pour
casperia Kim carrousel n'est pas il y a
toujours quelqu'un dans l'équipe il se
parle ce qu'on donne c'est pas un grand
maître
il y a toujours un mec c'est un
psychologue toujours depuis toujours
paraît-il que chez les Chinois enfin
chez l'équipe de Ding il y en a pas
d'antenne spécialiste parce que
il est en train de repère tout seul
et pour la énième fois dans ce match il
est en train de se auto détruire là
dans quoi eux deux
bon en défense le cavalier certes
mais ah oui ok ce compte
[Musique]
tu en penses quoi le Fab
surtout
ça fait plaisir bon allez let's go faire
la pause de toute façon il faut qu'on en
fasse trois donc il en reste encore
resté encore une derrière donc il faut
bien souffler la fable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Mesdames et Messieurs le retour de
fabibi yo yo
je vais faire une petite pause un tout
petit peu plus longue pour manger
et on a le Fab on a le Fab qui est là à
fond et qui va analyser tout comme il
faut
et qui va peut-être tu vas peut-être
pouvoir faire un comme toi tu as pas
forcément vu la partie tu peux peut-être
faire un
comme tu veux c'est toi
c'est plutôt bien si je fais si je fais
le récap
pour pour mettre dans le bain donc bah
déjà bonjour à tous j'espère que vous
allez bien que la partie vous plaît quel
animé bon ça on voit qu'elle est animée
ça peut être une partie décisive surtout
si ni pogne évidemment
c'est Ding égalis bravo mais comme d'hab
c'est animé alors vas-y on va
repartir à zéro et voir l'ouverture donc
c'était une Nimzo première fois du match
donc Ding tonnerre la nimo
il a joué que 3 le tirac et A3 donc un
site et oblige l'échange c'est un peu
débile de venir là pour repartir ici par
la suite donc il a pris prix
D6 ok
bon j'imagine qu'il y a plein de schémas
possible pour les Noirs mais des 6
pourquoi pas
cavalier 2 développements c'est Simco
qui avait les G3
donc il se place ici pour retenir le
centre éventuellement avancé
cavalier en C6 tour à deux coups
multifonctions qui permettent d'activer
la tour via la seconde rangée sans avoir
à développer tout le monde avant et puis
souvent quand on touche au pion F elle
peut donc venir appuyer là venir en deux
en deux en F2 avoir
B6 E4 c'est parti on avance
fois 6 oui bon de toute façon de mettre
leur set up en place pour venir taper
sur la faiblesse en
C4 donc il peut y aller à 5 qui vient
peut-être torse 8 etc et puis il échange
un jour pour prendre ce pion mais la
plupart du temps donc les blancs oui il
file le pion pour se concentrer sur
l'île d'âme après ça peut faire peur
parce qu'une fois qu'on a fait au 4 il
peut y avoir fouger 5 qui arrive et
on peut se prendre le bouillon avec les
Noirs donc il y a beaucoup de joueurs
qui qui se barre avec le cavalier mais
c'est souvent une bonne manœuvre
l'option est en D7 qui a joué avec des
ciseaux pourquoi quand le pion en dessin
parce que le cavalier peut venir en D6
il faut imaginer le pion ici et il tape
étape verset 4 avec fois 6 et on peut
jouer avec F5 pour bloquer l'avancée des
blancs sur sur la loi bon bref c'est
juste autre chose donc ça a l'air méga
dangereux pour les Noirs parce qu'après
H6 bah il fait H4 il dit bah ouais moi
je maintiens un clouage et puis si tu
prends ben j'ouvre la colonne h c'est un
fonc cavalier je débarque avec Madame
plus ou moins ce qui se passe sauf que
bon bah dépôt évidemment ne s'en va pas
avec le cavalier ça vous pouvez
comprendre c'est qu'elle s'en va et la
dame des marques et il fait G6 en
prenant du coup cette case à la dame
blanche pour pas laisser les blancs
venir doubler les pièces lourdes sur la
colonnage et au passage peut-être lui
donner du roi G7 torche 8 pour pour
colmater cette cette colonne ce sur quoi
Ding a pris le cavale dame prend et il
continue à envoyer avec E5 ce fil la
caisse de 4 pour le cavalier puis on
prend des 5 attaques l'autre cavaliers
qui s'en va et ici il y a sûrement deux
choix entre cavaliers 4 ou des 6 mais il
semblerait que cavalucate ne marchait
pas donc digne a pris du temps pour
réfléchir à tout ça et il a envoyé des
six mais bon il faut faire hein parce
que j'ai reçu et sous trop de pression
ici on va pas le laisser se faire
bouffer donc des 6 cavalier F5 Cavalo 4
attaque la dame qui vend des 8 et petit
à petit
[Musique]
on y est on est quasiment au moment où
du live donc Dame des trois étaient
joués il veut coulisser ok on comprend
les Noirs fontra G7 comme ça si la dame
vient il se prépare à Paris la menace
G4 chasse le cavalier et là excellente
décision de la part de nepo de ne pas
bouger et il a fait fou B7 en se disant
tiens si tu manges bon bah je reprends
et ce qui avait laissé il bouge je
prends ta tour et voilà et donc ça sera
gagnant pour la marque ce qui fait donc
après faut baisser Ding a bougé sa tour
en H3 et on emmenait là les amis voilà
pour le petit résumé donc tu auras H3 ça
enlève la tour de h1
du coup il a envie de prendre alors
après est-ce que les Noirs ne peuvent
quand même pas tolérer la prise en
disant ok ben je reprends parce que
niveau matériel à l'heure actuelle les
neurones plus prise ils ont une pièce de
moins mais quand deux pions donc ça
commence à ressembler à quelque chose
masse d'option centrale qui avance et
des 6 qui pourraient être bouffées donc
je pourrais faire trois pions pour la
tour assez facilement donc ils sont
peut-être pas obligés de d'enlever ce
cavalier de F5
avoir mais là du coup c'est méga
compliqué comme position
[Musique]
j'arrive comme ça comme une fleur je
tombe sur un truc il y en a de partout
et donc c'est dur d'expliquer plus juste
avec des mots maintenant c'est que de
variantes variante ah ça ça marche parce
que si ça ça marche pas parce que ça et
voilà donc
voilà après un petit point pendule parce
que ça peut avoir son importance comme
on l'a vu dans la partie précédente
Ding n'a plus que 36 minutes pour jouer
19 coups alors c'est faisable mais bon
si il plombe 20 minutes sur un coup ça
peut vite devenir compliqué et n'est pas
une heure cette fin un peu moins mais
ouais voilà
donc c'est chaud alors on me demande
pourquoi ça parle de lique de la prépa
de Ding sur les stream US alors ben
c'est pas un no fake en fait à priori
c'est vrai
et c'est un peu c'est un peu dommage
pour Ding là pour le coup alors c'est
quoi le truc c'est qu'en fait quand vous
allez sur les cheescom ou les chess
et que vous mettez la base de données en
ligne vous avez accès à toutes les
parties donc les joueurs réel dans les
tournois quoi mais aussi sur le sur le
site en question et en fait il y a eu si
vous souvenez la ronde 2 du champion du
monde Ding avait joué ça
H3 bon ok très bien mais c'est un truc
très rare enfin je sais pas qui va
rejouer H3 et aujourd'hui là il a fait
son truc bizarre dans l'ordre de coup
peut-être ou quoi avec tout rade
aussitôt etc et en fait il y a un pseudo
bon c'est pas trop enfin je sais pas
comment il est ce pseudo mais qui a joué
et cette position là et le 4h
le même pseudo je vous la même truc sur
cheesecam il y a un mois de ça
bon alors du coup on peut se deviner que
qu'il s'agit probablement de Ding qui
faisait des parties d'entraînement alors
je sais pas si ça avec rapport ou un
autre un autre second temps ou un ami à
lui grand maître j'en sais rien moi et
qui a essayé ces variantes là pour se
chauffer avant le match et prendre de
l'expérience
et du coup
du coup du coup voilà et là le problème
pour lui c'est que maintenant ça devient
flag autant qu'il y a un mec qui joue à
H3 bon on peut dire ok il joue H3 mais
[Musique]
là bon le mec fait H3 il fait aussi tour
à deux et puis chaque jour il fait le
même truc qui est au championnat du
monde il y a moins de ça il y a trop de
coïncidences donc là en fait le problème
c'est que bon j'imagine que la la team
nepo va juste aller télécharger les
parties
du pseudo en question et te regarder
et du coup Ding
va falloir innover parce que à sa place
je répéterai pas des trucs qu'il a déjà
le sur Internet
vu que souvent on l'intérêt c'est qu'il
y a quand même un effet de surprise
et puis bah là il y a plusieurs
surprises
[Musique]
voilà donc à priori
a priori voilà après j'en sais pas plus
que ce que je vous ai dit mais donc il y
a Elodie qui a mis un petit message
épinglé d'un poste Reddit dans le chat
voilà donc vous pouvez aller voir et
puis en apprendre un peu plus j'imagine
moi je sais pas plus que ça mais en gros
voilà c'est ça le truc mais pas malin
pas malin du tout d'avoir fait ça ça
c'est clair
ok il y a quelques années ça serait
passé inaperçu parce qu'il y avait
peut-être pas les mêmes options de
recherche etc il y aura plus de problème
mais ils auraient dû jouer je sais pas
en guest les pseudos enfin des voilà en
invité les parties sera peut-être pas
référencé ou sur d'autres sites ou
différemment ou s'inviter en réel et
puis personne sache parce que maintenant
c'est ouais mais c'est mon moderne quoi
c'est comme ça qu'on peut pas faire ça
donc oui c'est
c'est une graveur stratégique j'ai envie
de dire bon un truc c'est un truc qu'on
a jamais vu dans aucun match avant parce
que il y avait pas non plus autant de
moyens techniques avant mais là là voilà
quoi
donc ouais ça peut être un problème pour
Ding pour la suite du match qui
aura plus les rentes surprises en stock
c'est peut-être un leurre ah bah après
je sais pas enfin moi j'en sais pas plus
je peux pas vous dire plus
[Musique]
mais voilà c'est ça l'histoire qui vient
de sortir et futé aujourd'hui
alors de Ding ou de son équipe tous les
deux qui la responsabilité bah en fait
ils ont fait ça innovant ils ont pas
réfléchi que mais en fait à tous les
tailles compte à ce niveau là donc c'est
donc la faute à tout le monde j'ai envie
de dire il y a personne ça c'est
mais ça reste en importance évidemment
ça aurait pu se passer avant avec si tu
avais un mec dans ton équipe qui était
un espion ou qui qui était un double qui
donnait et prépa ton adversaire ce genre
de choses pouvaient arriver mais du coup
tu devrais en faire gaffe avoir
confiance au monde ton entourage ou
répartir les tâches et que tout le monde
ne soit pas au courant de tout du coup
au cas où il y a un problème il y a un
problème qui serait facile à bloquer
mais là oui maintenant maintenant voilà
quoi
et ouais mais du coup oui c'est une
erreur bête
après bah ouais comme j'espère qu'il
avait d'autres d'autres ouvertures
préparées ou qui pourra toujours faire
autre chose d'ici la fin mais à sa place
je rejouerai plus rien qui j'ai déjà
joué sur internet ça c'est clair
et du coup alors pour en revenir à la
partie mais donc c'est un épaule
bon c'est de comprendre un peu plus en
détail donc comme on disait les blancs a
priori la menace c'est de prendre mais
je sais pas à quel point c'est une
menace enfin une réelle menace puisque
peut-être les noirs sont pas mécontents
de reprendre comme on a dit
donc qu'est-ce qui peut jouer cela dit
avec les Noirs donc bon son on part avec
le cavalier donc on a deux cases dispo
soit on va contester la colonne soit on
monte peut-être la dame pour lier les
tours et contester bon on va analyser un
peu si vous voulez on va regarder
c'est une connerie immédiate sur un joli
truc tactique hop là
tourage 7 et fourchette donc Dame des 7
éliminer
hop pas de Dame des 7 alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a dit d'autre on peut bouger le
cavalier
il se passe quoi se en quatre à
quel point on peut regarder aussi si tu
veux je vous prends 4 bon on reprend qui
prend des 6 winner c'est dans la liste
des coûts envisageables après moi
j'avais un peu peur de comprenne ça
parce que ce que je voyais c'est qu'on
pouvait pas faire de la miftys puisque
il y a encore le même coup de tour H7
bon au pire vous me direz et bon ok
terminé on gagne la dame et le roi la
tour va un moment arriver et faire
mettre donc pas de Dam F6 cela dit il y
a pion F6 qui jouable
ce qui est jouable les blancs peuvent
pas prendre ce pion il s'aligne avec le
roi donc peut-être damage 2 pour aller
créer des problèmes là-bas
un point de détail important il n'y a
pas tourage 8 puisqu'on prend la dame
doit reprendre et elle laisserait le
cavalier en prise du coup ça a l'air
dangereux pour les noirs
alors bon il se trouve que ça gagne pas
pour les blancs d'après le petit ordi
qui dit cavalier F7 défend et chaque
fois j'ai 8 et tout tient bon souvent un
qui avait la proximité du roi c'est un
super défenseur et là on a encore un
exemple mais du coup voyant ça je j'ai
du mal à croire que n'est pas va rentrer
là-dedans parce que on se dit ouais ce
fou un moment il va se ramener je sais
pas j'ai retour des deux gagnants fou
ici attaque ça c'est trop dangereux pour
les Noirs ça je peux pas croire qu'il va
qui va rentrer là-dedans
donc à mon avis ça n'aura pas lieu ça ne
variante
donc
qu'est-ce qui peut faire on m'a dit il
peut bouger le cavalier alors ce qui
peut faire ça il peut toujours faire ça
c'est un coup voilà esquive la menace
[Musique]
c'est pas bête
il peut peut-être bien bien ancrer ce
qui avait ici j'aime bien l'idée en fait
c'est peut-être un coup que je pourrais
envisager perso un sujet noir en me
disant si j'arrive à faire ça et F6 par
exemple je bloque tout sa colonnage il a
misé tout son jeu là dessus on en parle
plus donc
l'ordi il propose G5
pour attaquer la dame et toi je suis à
ce moment là pour le défendre
et pas clair et pas clair
là il y a pas de grande conclusion à
tirer c'est chaud
c'est chaud mais bon là par contre les
normes très clairement faut prendre le
cadre d'un problème
on peut pas laisser ça à côté blanc donc
faut soit je vais peut-être dame G3 et
sur fupron cavalier se venger sur
celui-là
et puis il faut bouger le fou alors je
sais pas si on va là ou de l'autre côté
bon pas clair mais
bon encore lui
[Musique]
ouais franchement ça ça m'inquiète très
côté noir plus ou moins peut-être prise
je sais pas où j'irai que le fou
peut-être là pourquoi là j'ai pas un cui
bouge en fait disons si je fais ça c'est
juste un exemple je me prends échec je
m'en vais lui il bouge
3 F4
la tour elle débarque
chaud du coup le fond F3 peut-être qui
bloque ce genre d'idée
sur quoi j'aurais dit tour des deux moi
pour regarder si tu peux me mettre en
passer et j'en sais rien comment juger
cette position
il y a un peu plus pour les Noirs il y a
beaucoup de pions doublés de partout il
y a toujours des menaces la tente vers
le roi mais je crois plus qu'on va mater
maintenant donc ça c'est jouable pour
les Noirs à mon avis
c'est jouable pour les noirs
[Musique]
position il peut se passer des trucs
mais plus ou moins correct après bon je
peux revenir l'ordi il donne des choses
dans ma cheville de 0-0 il dit e4006
donc en gros pour dire que c'est que ça
joue quoi donc ça c'est vraiment une
ligne possible cette histoire de
cavalier H4 après ton H3 c'est pas un
mauvais coup du tout il y a vraiment de
convoi elles sont pas inhumaines ou
c'est pas juste des trucs d'ordi donc ok
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre qui avait H6
on avait dit alors ça paraît plus
bizarre que le H6 là il pouvait venir
ici on voulait faire G5 là il se met
vraiment hors-jeu donc j'aime pas
tellement que ce soit à cause de F3 pour
le cloisonner loin du jeu ou même pour
aller l'enfoncer parce que tout à
l'heure on pouvait prendre le problème
c'est que maintenant on se prend un
échec
donc s'il vient là à rebouger on va
reconstruire tout champion F ramener le
tour derrière et on a juste fait un
aller-retour pour rien donc KFC c'est
débile
[Musique]
d'après l'ordi mais j'aime pas du tout
donc cavalier H4 coup correct pour
l'instant je pencherai sur celui-là et
dernière option qu'on a dit alors d'un
des 7 et des billes aussi à cause de ton
hashtag facile dernier option c'est au
huit laisse le cavalier en prise
donc est-ce qu'on prend d'abord à ce
qu'on prend ici j'en sais rien
regardons regardons ça
cavalier alors je sais pas si on va vers
l'avant ou l'arrière mais ça c'est des
positions
chaotiques intéressantes
pour la pièce
ce qui passe censé être assez
normalement il faut au moins trois pions
mais d'ici je sais pas combien de temps
on va le maintenir en vie il peut plus
avancer plus loin le roi va venir va
essayer d'aller ici et une masse de
pions centraux les pièces sont un peu
inactives donc c'est clairement un choix
intéressant
basiquement voilà sur ce qu'on vient de
voir il y a deux coups qui me semblent
intéressant c'est que tu auras suite ou
cavalier H4
le reste peut être plus ou moins éliminé
un coup correct comme on a vu avec
l'ordi mais bon je peux pas imaginer
qu'il va rentrer là-dedans
une des deux après ça dépend son rapport
avec le matériel si ça le dérange pas
d'avoir une pièce de moins ou si il
préfère l'autre je
moi sur ce que je vois limite je
partirai sur ton site mais bon je peux
pas dire de mal de cavalier H4 ça c'est
un coup correct mais quel H4 c'est plus
ça me semble plus indécis alors tora8
surtout la situation du match ou une
époque a déjà un point d'avance donc bon
nul avec les noirs
on prend voilà maintenant si on fait du
statut quo il y a pas de souci mais
voilà ce genre de position là
je me sentirai pas trop en danger avec
les Noirs en fait
peut-être le jugement mais
alors ça j'ai pas regardé
mais j'en sais rien je sais pas si on
fait f63 F6 d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
un coup peut-être F6 je plane tout
voilà bon ok on a une pièce devant mais
bon lui il peut vraiment être vite
complètement en dehors du jeu quoi
bloqué par ce foulard bloqué par la
masse des pions et le roi
[Musique]
mais sinon l'autre coup aussi que je
trouve un peu safe et G5 j'aimerais bien
mettre en place bon je fais un coup
neutre pour les blancs mais juste bon on
va dire je défends mon truc si jamais je
peux faire un truc comme ça là je pense
je suis hyper content avec
ça serait genre de mes objectifs de
blinder qui est plus de passage sur la
colonage au pire je vais empêcher les
sacrifice de qualité là-bas après je
m'occupe de lui je prends des 6 et puis
je suis très heureux quoi j'ai
l'impression d'avoir très très bien
sécurisé ma situation donc dame j'ai
trois je serais content de faire G5 plus
que de prendre le cadre et des CH4 après
bon ça c'est un goût perso mais j'aime
pas tellement côté blanc et d'un me
prend le problème je pense qu'il est 600
attaque la dame tu peux plus rester au
contact du cavalier sauf ici mais là bon
il y a les tours qui vont marcher vous
et tout ré 8 et c'est la merde
c'est le retour retour de Kev ouais il
va me lâcher une info quand même
des échanges info pour info vas-y c'est
quoi l'ingrédient principal de Larissa
parce que c'est tellement bon
du piment si vous voulez l'info comment
faire Larry sa maison et je vous lâche
l'info de Vannes non moi je ferai je te
le dis comme ça sans jamais en avoir
fait je n'ai entendu une réduction de
tomates un peu comme du concentré de
tomates quoi avec du piment c'est
tellement bon et peut-être un peu un peu
d'huile on est d'accord que c'est
exceptionnel
ou pas je suis hyper content de moi quoi
pour info
puis on prend et puis on prend
il va avancer mais je pense qu'il a pas
joué à cause de sûrement la première
ligne de l'ordi
c'est le plus humain est-ce que tu
regardes
il a fait quoi pour le coup
moi humain mais toi
et ça va faire la ligne qu'on avait
depuis tout à l'heure ouais
et tu auras ensuite ils disent peut-être
cavalier F6 dans le chat ici
c'est une option en fait non il y a
beaucoup d'options en fait ils sont très
compliquées
ou je sais pas peut-être mais
si ce 4 temps
on bouffe la case
surtout quand tu as pas trop de casse
pour le roi ou tu as envie d'aller en
fait parce que dès un jour tu te prends
en échec et eux tu bloques
bon tu auras plus de toute façon c'est
forcé et dames G3 direct attends c'est
ce truc avec fupr 4
[Musique]
ok ouais peut-être avec les Blancs
que l'autre
bon en fait on a un gros problème avec
notre fou avec les Blancs quand même
que je le vois chaque fois donc harissa
purée de piment
quel piment
là c'est bon
pas de tomate
que du piment
avec du pain et de l'huile d'olive c'est
bon c'est bien ouais
après oui en plus tu peux doser
[Musique]
c'est plutôt asiatique non
il va le jouer tôt ou tard
oui parce que
[Musique]
donc
on n'est pas venu H4 pour repartir en F5
si on fait ça arrive F3 F4 ou je sais
pas quoi et
la tour à deux va enfin dévoiler
pourquoi elle est là ces intentions
en pleine forme et tout ça va mais quand
tu commences à perdre la concentration
et que et que tu craques un peu ou tu
commences à avoir du mal à bien calculer
c'est le genre de truc tu peux oublier
et puis en plus si il a bien mis entre 1
et à deux on sait pas trop à un moment
il a double un peu il la recache de plus
en plus et un moment
tu es fatigué tu vois pas qu'elle est
tout rouge pas comme ça
mère Michel qui normalement c'est pas
contre les règles de se lever de sa
chaise alors que ça son temps de jouer
alors oui mais il était parti avant en
fait il a joué son cou avant des pots il
est parti bah Ding a répondu mais là du
coup il est plus là donc là c'est pas
c'est pas illégal je ne reviens pas
je suis parti j'ai vu que tu as joué
mais je vais pas revenir
un peu tu sais pas trop quoi jouer
une bonne technique si tu veux qu'on
quelqu'un tu penses qui triche tu joues
tout à fait sur sa chaîne
tu t'appelles
tu te rends compte que le gars un pseudo
qui a été ban
là tu es tenté de jouer tout tempo pour
le laisser assis quoi bah oui oui après
on est sur durant le risque de jouer
moins bien vu que tu joues tempo mais je
préfère jouer moins bien que mon niveau
intrinsèque mais quand même je suis sûr
que j'ai contre la personne que tu vois
tu sais pas sinon ce qui est capable de
faire donc tu le laisses pas tu le
laisses pas partir ouais
c'est une technique non mais
intéressante
ça veut dire quoi jouer tempo
[Musique]
même moins normalement quand même
mais non enfin ça non tu as pas le droit
mais juste si tu t'es barré que le mec
joue tu t'es pas rendu compte qu'il ait
jouait ou quoi on peut rien dire tu
étais pas là tu étais pas là
si il se mange un gros kebab il a le
droit
sur la table de jeu tu as le droit ou
pas ou c'est considéré comme
[Musique]
en fait je pense que tu as le droit de
tout mais si ton adversaire se plaint ça
l'arbitre après de voir si ton
comportement est
correct ou pas mais je pense si tu veux
manger un sandwich et ton anniversaire
dis rien qui s'en fout bah quelque chose
du coup
aller manger en salle de repos ou du
coup tu as le droit de faire ça sur ton
temps j'imagine dans ce cas-là tu veux
pas qu'il mange à table du coup
je vais avoir une fringale je dois
manger
un cigare c'est interdit moi ça m'est
arrivé d'avoir un adversaire qui
arrêtait pas de péter ça puait toute la
partie et c'est pas interdit ça j'ai
vécu d'expérience mais faut non mais ça
tu as pas le droit tu as le droit genre
toute la partie ou chier dans son froc
ça c'est autorisé non mais ça met
vraiment arrivé
à côté de la semaine quoi cette partie
j'arrivais juste pas à me concentrer non
mais c'est insupportable
mais déjà arrivé
deux fois et je vais proposer nulle
tellement j'étais écœuré mais l'arbitre
m'a pas donné la victoire
c'était déjà arrivé de dégager le mec
c'est pas possible dernièrement du
championnat de France si j'ai gagné la
partie j'aurai fini premier execo mais
l'arbitre il a rien fait
ou quoi mais une fois deux fois ok je
propose une j'en pouvais plus quoi mais
l'arbitre non il a il nous avait fait
chier
de toute façon les arbitres je pense tu
viens juste tu casses la gueule du mec
comme c'est du MMA et puis tu vas
l'arbitre va rien dire en fait j'ai
gagné le mec le mec ne peut plus jouer
non mais là c'est pas possible
il a rechangé
tu as une sorte de Clément Turpin des
échecs table 3 champion
mais non ça m'est arrivé ouais
deux fois sur les
non il y a rien il joue
ouais
j'ai eu ça et j'ai eu quoi oui j'ai eu
un jour mais ça j'avais déjà raconté
mais le mais j'étais petit j'avais
peut-être 10 11 ans j'avais un
adversaire qui était un peu en surpoids
genre deux fois toi qui était tombé en
arrière sur la chaîne et qui m'avait mis
un de coup de pied avec des
chaussures pointues qui avait fait un
hématomotibia mais un hématome
moi j'ai perdu cinq fois après mais
l'appareil c'est enfin normalement tu
donnes le gain quand même enfin il a pas
fait exprès mais bon voilà je suis pas
sûr je donnerais le mec qui vomit c'est
sûr que je laisse pas enfin
hématome où tu dois garder ça parce que
ça peut être dangereux ok enfin je veux
bien que ce soit à volontaire mais un
moment donné il y a des limites
j'avais vraiment un gros hématome quoi
j'aurais pu avoir
amputation mais je sais pas ça aurait pu
être quelque chose qui demande une
intervention grande graine du pied
je sais pas quelque chose de cassé ou
quoi
mais là pareil tu as dit non non ça joue
il y a pas de problème
ouais
tu casses la gueule non mais bon j'ai
glissé chef
pas le droit de faire dans un tournoi
d'échec
en réalité
je sais pas quel est quels sont les
limites
c'est pas moi déjà
mais
ouais bon globalement les gens sont
censés se retenir par eux-mêmes quoi
ça me paraît évident ouais mais là après
quelqu'un glisse te met un coup de pied
même s'il fait un hématome c'est
involontaire je sais pas
le bon parti gagner ça me paraîtrait
quand même normal
le mec qui fait ça mais toute la partie
le mec a été que
ça ça peut arriver dans les avions ça
peut arriver
bon
qui va partir dame G3 celle que tu as
montré et remontrer à plusieurs reprises
du coup bon c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant tout ce qui peut arriver
parce que
en fait moi j'étais sur ce truc là qui
me semble plutôt pas mal au noir là avec
genre déjà tu reprends pas obligé mais
admettons et foulage je voulais faire
planter le fou et quel elle saute plus
quoi
et je lui dis ça ça va pour les normes
mais c'est pour ça je préfère largement
le truc que
de bouffer ça parce que là il faut faire
j'imagine et on a un fou pourri mais
c'est plus ouvert et on peut avoir un
rêve qui remplace la dame ou j'en sais
rien qui fasse un truc un jour
mais l'un dans l'autre on va dire que
mes pots s'en sort pas mal chaque
position qu'on voit
je sais pas ce qu'il faut jouer ici mais
je comprends que tu puissiez tu dois
regarder tiens tour des deux ce que le
pion est chiant sont bien placé
finalement le fou qui a pas de cas c'est
vrai mais il est développé en F1 oui bah
il défend un peu les gens il évite les
kg de il peut donner en Détroit enfin
peut-être un jour
je te défends non mais c'est vraiment
plus il défend un peu les tours H1 il
peut tu peux venir là
je viens ici
là il défend H3 attendez
[Musique]
on va voir la suite c'est peut-être
terminé est-ce que l'ordi ce plante ou
peut-être tu veux faire des dames G5
dames C1 mais que ça aboutit nulle part
alors attends on va voir ça parce que
Tam G5 le problème
et sûrement jusqu'au 2 et quand il veut
faire dame prend ses trois peut-être
[Musique]
terminé c'est sûr
ça c'est ce qu'il a vu alors que on va
voir ce qu'il a pas vu mon tour des deux
c'est quand même
plus que logique tu peux regarder
d'abord parce que je l'aurais pas direct
mais en fait je veux depuis tout à
l'heure c'est pour ceux qui me paraît
logique mais
tourner
en fait
et tu fais des 7 ouais mais ok c'est
facile c'est pas si dur hein
il doit pas être bien il s'est levé
ouais hé il doit pas être bien nepo et
ça va faire quatre partout mesdames et
messieurs
c'est pas de bol c'est pas de bol
il a il a raté il a raté
ah c'est trop c'est trop ce match
ah c'est trop il a raté ça
il a raté ça et des 7 et dans ma part
mais c'est relativement facile je veux
dire
[Musique]
ça c'est quoi le problème juste pour
pour savoir pour moi d'apprendre ici je
parle là-bas
ton rêve 8
déjà en fait moi là
en fait on va à la place de décès je
voulais déjà tourner deux en fait moi ça
fait longtemps que je vais faire tourner
deux parce qu'en fait c'est un de mes
défauts des fois mais j'ai trop de mal à
pas justifier un coup pendant longtemps
et ça m'énerve trop et j'aurais fait
tourner deux juste parce que ah tiens
regarde ma tour elle sert à quelque
chose tu es pas là spectateur du jeu
mais je veux dire que je l'aurais envoyé
trop tôt mais du coup c'est pour ça que
je voulais regarder F4 moi ça me semble
logique mais merci au revoir
mais c'est Ding c'est dur de comprendre
ce qu'il fait
en fait il a l'air complètement à côté
de ses pompes une fois sur deux
psychologiquement quoi
et puis chaque fois il revient et en
fait il te fait des grosses parties là
il a bien il joue bien quoi
on a vraiment jamais
jamais c'est pas possible
j'ai rarement vu les Noirs quoi
tu te fais défoncer il y a aucune
particulière 4h
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais vu ça entre
leak et les deux abrutis qui jouent des
parties ensemble
pour la suite du match
aussi abruti quand même c'est
parce qu'en fait même à ton niveau on le
sait déjà bah à mon niveau aussi ce que
je te disais tout à l'heure moi quand
les mecs ils sont top
j'avais fait une fois avec Mazo de
quelques parties j'allais en guest
tu me retrouve pas quoi je crée pas de
pseudo c'est pour ça que c'est gros moi
j'ai encore du mal à imaginer que ce
soit possible de faire une telle
connerie
ça paraît quand même oui mais ils l'ont
fait là
[Musique]
qui est tout
là c'est plus possible c'est plus il y a
un mois de ça c'est pas il y a 6 ans
comment c'est possible en fait
on en reparlera dans la vidéo
le truc épinglé
parce que c'est des trucs au niveau
amateur tu sais déjà même Stone qui se
prépare comme ça en regardant les
petites choses comme donc c'est même pas
penser tiens on crée un pseudo que c'est
pas moi je mets pas mon nom et en prend
pas le pseudo GM machin
on s'en fout et ils vont pas nous
trouver quoi parce que oui si tu crains
un pseudo
xx1213
[Musique]
qui va aller voir mais le problème c'est
que maintenant tu peux regarder la
position dans les parties qu'on a
regardé rapidement avec là il y a des
parties qui pouvaient pas du tout
correspondre au match du championnat du
monde donc est-ce que c'est rapport qui
a fait n'importe quoi tu vois c'est dur
à dire
ah mais là tu mets deux trois mecs sur
le coup tu regardes
ce qui peut être bien ou pas
je sais pas c'est étonnant bah c'est
étonnant mais après ouais nous il y
avait des parties qui pouvaient pas
correspondre au match mais peut-être ces
rapports ce qui a fait d'autres trucs à
côté enfin on sait pas en fait
après si c'est fait exprès pour se faire
attraper c'est beau quoi et que tu
préviens un mec de faire le lit à ce
moment là
bon là c'est niveau qui s'est passé tout
seul parce qu'en fait juste quand tu
regardes tu tombes dessus dans les bases
de données je sais pas c'est très
étonnant
mais c'est con pas possible en vrai
c'est évident que il faut pas le faire
en fait d'avance tu sais que il faut pas
le faire
pourquoi échec
fait chez Cora et attaque le cahier des
6 et donc en plus vous deux et faire F6
il y a pas d'autres mots
de ne pas avoir utilisé la bonne
plateforme il mérité en fait
ils ont utilisé une chasse comme parce
que j'ai compris mais l'équipe
antitriche de chasse comme a bien marché
puisqu'elle a pas de mes comptes
donc voilà ça prouve que tu as comme
ce que tu es efficace sur la triche ou
quoi c'est quand même assez efficace
ils ont vraiment en fait
même si on commente comme quoi le truc
c'est que le le secteur antitriche c'est
un secteur très secret donc on a pas
d'informations ça fuit pas justement bah
parce que si ça fuitait ça serait facile
de savoir si ça fait pas faire en vrai
ça c'est les choses on a vraiment zéro
information
confidentielle c'est c'est impossible de
les avoir mais de notre ressenti de
personnes qui jouent beaucoup sur
cheescom surtout moi qui vont encore
plus que toi mais toi tu joues pas mal
et avec Baki dans les titles etc et avec
Maxime on en a aussi parlé c'est qui il
y a vraiment un gros boulot sur la
triche là qui a été fait dernièrement
côté de chasse comme ça fait plaisir et
ben un petit rush hier à 28,75 quand
même côté français mais tu vois aussi
parce que bah tu te fais moins fermer
donc forcément
donc un vrai truc qui est fait et bah là
ça tend à le prouver puisque c'est
contre là d'entraînement qui sont pas
des comptes autorisés en fait ben ouais
ben quoi
non mais par contre faudrait qu'il y ait
une option
je joue cachais il y a une option
ok bah il faut demander l'autorisation
je la demande moi ça m'intéresse pas du
tout de jouer et que les mecs prennent
parti de chaise comme ça contre moi quoi
enfin non mais tu as le droit d'avoir un
compte caché mais il faut le demander
mais là où tu vas te faire fermer c'est
qu'en fait les gens après ils aiment pas
jouer contre vraiment tu sais pas du
coup tu te rends plus d'adversaire mais
tu peux plus jouer
non mais c'est vraiment chiant ce truc
qu'on puisse te télécharger
tout le monde anonyme et que c'est le
festivalent tout ils disent quitter et
qui est plus l'historique des parties
qui ne soit pas téléchargeable ça sert à
rien
non mais ça c'est pas possible ça même
pas deux en fait
pas téléchargeable c'est juste
impossible tu gardes pas d'historique
et si tu veux les laisser dispo
non mais si toi tu les veux pour toi
pour te les analyser ou tu laisses sur
ton public sur ton profil public si tu
as envie mais si moi je veux pas que tu
accède ah mais il faut que tu adversaire
du coup tu joues pas mais c'est chiant
enfin
dont toi suite
du coup
ensuite on va prendre 5 ça a l'air
ouais bon je sais pas trop il prend
ce que ça veut dire que quand je vais te
faire dames.5 tu auras plus rager 8 tu
auras plus juste on est obligé de se
retrouver
bon c'est sûr que c'est mieux que tout
ce qu'on a vu plus tôt oui bah là j'en
ai une finale on a pu en 17 on a foutu
pour les s'y accrocher ça va être ça va
être bien
alors
ou pas j'en sais rien mais peut-être
c'est dur
bah tu veux te prendre ça
en fait c'est le tour à jeu qu'on a
depuis tout à l'heure sauf que H2 on le
tient plus maintenant je dis de la merde
désolé
en fait c'est facile ouais pas facile ça
dépend à quel point il juge que la
finale est bien dans l'autre oui parce
que si l'autre il se dit très bien il
peut aller dans l'autre il y a beaucoup
d'options donc c'est ça qui rend le truc
pas facile mais s'il y avait que cette
option là une fois que tu l'as vu enfin
tu peux y penser mais bon ça va il a 35
minutes quoi direct alors le problème
c'est quoi
qui recommence et tout à l'heure ce qui
avait de pas bien c'était que
deux fois
donc là ça change tout on aura un tour
des trop intercalé qui change beaucoup
de choses
on aurait perdu un thème
tu laisses F6 est-ce que c'est grave
c'est un grand mot c'est juste c'est pas
aussi gagnant quoi
non mais en fait c'est pour ça que tu
peux te retrouver
à jouer un truc comme ça
faut qu'il ait le tour des trois
et si là on aura une nouvelle fois une
partie courte c'est vrai que ce
championnat du monde classique nous
offre que des parties rapides oui ça
c'est incroyable peut-être pour ça qu'il
est si apprécié et que tout le monde dit
waouh génial en fait ça dure pas à 8h
quoi on n'a jamais le temps de trop se
faire chier ouais
et donc pour la ricin j'ai vraiment la
confirmation parce que j'ai un ami
cuisinier qui suit et qui me dit piment
rouge ail huile mais quel piment rouge
en fait
c'est ça en fait c'est l'info que je
vais avoir bah là je pense tu as le
choix
ouais mais c'est quoi genre le piment
rouge le plus main quoi
c'est quoi genre celui qui est réputé
pour donner le goût le plus fin
bon ça vaut pas il y a beaucoup de gens
qui font de Larissa maison ou pas
alors moi j'en ai jamais fait bah si la
recette
mais
ouais enfin à priori sur ce que je crois
voir ce qu'on appelle si durable à faire
car
du format mais ce serait pas lui qui est
le rang le plus ennuyeux non parce qu'il
y a beaucoup de match quand même
ennuient avant crâne ni Teko etc c'était
un double truc bon déjà les gens sont
très combatifs bon ça c'est tout à
l'heure honneur mais en plus il y a le
fait qu'il y a pas droit de faire
proposition de nul avant le 40e coup qui
change beaucoup ça non il y avait des
nuls rapides parce que tu es dans une
crainte réciproque personne ne prend 3D
tu dis bon allez je propose nul j'ai pas
eu ce que je voulais dans l'ouverture et
bon bah l'autre il est content il fait
nul aussi il allait noir bon ok ben là
peut-être qu'ils ont été dans cet esprit
n'est pas dans la française ou et qu'il
aurait pu proposer nul s'il avait le
droit mais tu peux pas tu joues quoi et
du coup ils sont de force à jouer
peut-être un moment tu vas plus faire de
conneries que sinon
donc il y a ça qui joue par rapport au
vieux match et donc par rapport à
récemment oui mais Carlson c'est son
style de jeu de de jouer pour ne pas
faire d'erreur de jouer des parties
lentes enfin longues t'amener peut-être
en finale même des positions un peu
mortes mais lui il cherche toujours à te
faire jouer un coup de plus un coup de
plus etc et c'est comme ça
mais je dois dire
enfin dans les matchs précédents on
avait eu énormément de finale ou après
trois heures de jeu c'était clair que ça
allait faire nul mais que ça a joué
peut-être encore pendant deux trois
voire même quatre heures c'est arrivé on
est des buts c'est de fatiguer l'autre
si tu te sens bien sûr non non mais ça
fait partie d'une stratégie de match
c'est pas c'est pas une critique envers
les joueurs mais du coup ça
c'est pas un plaisir à regarder alors
que là c'est c'est vrai que
ça et ça clique quoi
et ça dure jamais longtemps j'ai une
question sur le chat qui nous demandait
s'ils ont pour le droit de répéter si si
par contre tu peux faire nul avant le
40e si tu fais trois fois la même
position ou
pas tu vois enfin si il y a une vraie
règle de nul où il y a nul il est nul
quoi
bon pas de c'est dur mais
si c'est chaud d'accord on fait quoi
donc tu vois ce que je veux dire quoi
tu as le droit quoi
c'est exactement ça c'est beaucoup de
matchs qui sont vraiment très ennuyeux
mais en fait quand tu vois ces parties
là très franchement tu aurais une
cadence de 1h36 30 secondes par coup et
juste en rajoute une demi-heure au 4e
pour laquelle plaid Mathieu cornette
depuis un certain moment mais
franchement pour ce match là sans rien
changer par exemple non pas grand chose
et pour les autres matchs qui sont un
peu ennuyeux ben au contraire ça force
enfin oui ça empêcherait en fait c'est
parti qui dure un peu trop quoi mais bon
ça fait quand même 1h30 enfin même 1h40
+ 30 secondes allez on va maintenant 30
secondes et les 38 30 + 30 secondes ça
peut quand même te donner des parties de
5h30 6h
c'est pas non plus une cadence courte
quoi
mais ça t'enlève
ça fait que la plupart des partiels
duraient entre ouais 3h45 et 5h quoi un
peu comme ce match là en réalité
ouais ouais mais là c'est une bonne
[Musique]
c'est bien ce match en fait parce que
oui c'est vrai qu'on a pas les parties
trop trop longues c'est animé on sait
jamais à quoi s'attendre
et même là bon elle est pas encore
gagnée dans l'ordi monte très haut dans
les tours mais parce que
[Musique]
moi je suis content par contre si la
tour des trois je pense enfin par contre
si la tourage fuite d'un match de tour
des trois là je pense qu'il y a plus de
manière de rater parce que ça va être
tour des 8 disons pour arrêter le pion
tout rage 3 et le problème c'est que bah
on va se retrouver dans une prochaine
mais oui donc faut avoir cette idée faut
pas se perdre avec des dettes qui vont
mal ou quoi donc voilà quoi
les échecs classiques seraient parti et
moi j'ai toujours été très très clair
sur sur ce que je pensais moi je pense
qu'il faut trois circuits en fait un
circuit rapide un circuit rapide et un
circuit en partie longue tu veux dire un
blitz
pardon et
rapide et
laisser un peu enfin juste ajouter des
choses mais pas avoir des calendriers
qui se marchent dessus quoi voir des
saisons bien bien définies et puis ils
vont après partie classique oui c'est
pas obligé que ce soit des parties de 8h
non plus quoi ah mais ça une à 1h30
moi j'aime bien le 1h30 en fait
15 minutes ça évite de saccager les
finales peut-être mais en même temps ça
te force à mieux les travailler voire
des bons réflexes plutôt que de faire
que du calcul donc je sais pas en fait
enfin les deux peuvent se défendre mais
rajouter au 40e pourquoi pas mais déjà
1h30 30 secondes c'était pas mal et
surtout Camille comme au tennis a que
des tournois en jeu c'est fini la
multitude de tournois qui servent à rien
que des manettes à un tour à chaque fois
tu as un numéro un mondial à la fin du
truc est un numéro mondial global
d'ailleurs ce serait aussi la grande
différence c'est que tu aurais battu
aurait pu marquerais des points en blitz
tu marques des points rapides tu marques
des points en longue et à la fin tu as
quand même un numéro mondial
global donc après tu vois oui lui il est
plus fort en billets c'est plus fort
rapide machin et quitte après à garder
quand même un match de championnat du
monde ça fait plaisir quoi pourquoi pas
à la fin le match entre le 1 et le de
l'année où j'en sais rien quoi même
beaucoup de points qui te met numéro un
mondial ou non du coup se qualifie et tu
prends les deux trois quatre cinq tu
fais une sorte de playoff comme au
rugbyte les mecs arrivent non plus non
mais pas trop long sur deux jours tu
vois enfin c'est bon quoi
on débarque le lundi le mercredi on joue
la finale des candidats
et puis on sait après quoi
en tout cas je pense qu'avoir trois
types de saison ou alors le le classique
la saison classique elle te qualifie à
la fin quand même pour ma femme donc il
a fait tourner la suite
mais il est pas très nerveux il est plus
il est il est bien il sera indigne
a changé le circuit pour faire comme au
tennis et ben c'est incroyable ah mais
moi je suis sûr que tu avoir les au lieu
d'avoir tout un tas de circuits de trucs
qui servent à rien tu as 16 ans rapide
les gens sont contents après tu as ta
saison longue bah les gens sont contents
et fin de l'année tu as ta saison bleed
enfin peut-être l'été tu as comme la
saison 12 bis ça ne doit pas être longue
un mois tiens c'est torcher quoi non non
mais c'est bien va c'est lisible en plus
parce que le nombre de fois on n'arrive
pas à vous expliquer
pourquoi ce truc a lieu ou tel autre ou
il l'a pas mais ça a l'air c'était le
truc qu'on regardait le premier truc il
est bien quand même mais il va peut-être
pas gagner sur le champ
non mais il est bien quand même mais
ouais donc tordez trois tour des trois
tu vois pas si
facilement
on a une case de dames le fou qui fait
rien il peut aller en jet d'eau C6 le
défendre donc il y a beaucoup de choses
qui font qu'on a envie de le faire on a
un purement mais bon le 5 on se dit on
va le récupérer peut-être je vais mettre
madame en C7 ou de jouer la finale donc
peut-être enfin avoir une finale en fait
d'ailleurs en ce match
ok mais donc là ça peut durer un peu
mais je sentais bien le rater quand même
le temps de travail paraissait dur enfin
dur parce que le décès de paraît bien
mais c'est ça le truc si c'est ce qu'on
disait ça dépend à quel comment il
estime il évalue le décès
et donc on va voir
à cause de décès
en fait si décède donne vraiment rien tu
dis merde mais quand même j'ai
l'impression d'être bien est-ce que j'ai
pas mieux et tu cherches autre chose et
voilà mais du coup toi il a donc même
pas regardé quoi
on va voir
sinon tant pis enfin je sais pas quoi
dire quoi
quand même
mais bon après c'est quand même
c'est quand même bien quoi pour lui la
position
et
ça a l'air pas mal quoi
pour une raison qui m'échappe leur dit
il veut vraiment le ranger 7
machin peut-être je sais pas
après je vais dire
non mais j'imagine que là en fait il va
cumuler des choses il a son dessin il va
peut-être un jour faire F4 pour tout
défendre il peut aussi bouffer la tour
pour aller vers H2 si il faut il pourra
bouger son fou en g2c6 comme on a dit
pour les soutenir le pion peut-être que
tu peux faire un truc c'est roi des un
Roissy de rabb3 tu te caches tu es plus
touchable et même tu continues les Noirs
je vois pas comment il bouge en fait en
B5 et enfin tu vas très loin qu'en fait
tous et
on va mettre son coup déjà d'enfant à 7
est-ce que c'est possible
[Musique]
c'est normal il veut normal quand on est
mieux et qu'il y a un ZZ note qui
approche ne refait pas dans le sens
pas qu'ils puissent non non normalement
là il fait dames c'est 7
voilà non c'est juste qu'il a peu de
temps
et il se lève
non non ça lui approche ça lui approche
le 40e quand même ça lui a fait gagner
trois coups
j'adorerais voir celui-là
[Musique]
faire ça quoi
non mais sinon oui j'aimerais bien
l'amener là-bas là où il est tranquille
le mettre là faire dame C8 et voilà ça
c'est j'aime bien le plan
[Rires]
ce serait bon en fait que tu m'aimes pas
les couilles
j'arrive
[Musique]
des amis sérieux voilà j'ai la dame C7
le son des 7 tu as parlé de la tournée
prépare-toi quoi
non c'est bon on est pas loin de pouvoir
vraiment le faire
c'est con qui c'est E5 là comme contre
le sinon
bien se passer
peut-être on doit remettre une pub enfin
je sais pas
[Musique]
le temps de les mettre des trois mais là
du coup je me dis on peut mettre la pub
ça va quoi on peut mettre la petite pub
on revient dans une dizaine de minutes à
tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Fab il s'est passé deux trois
coups depuis qu'on est parti à vrai dire
l'ordi aime pas du tout mais on
discutait un petit peu on comprend pas
pourquoi on regarde sans ordi en fait
quand on est en pause il a fait ta Mach
4 en fait tu peux bouffer la tour
alors pour faire tourner
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est introuvable si
c'est calculer quand
il a perdu un tempo
de la partie là quand tu vas mettre les
valses comme
ça va pas être terrible
et c'est quoi là pour le 5 c'est si con
disait qu'il y ait Descartes alors je
sais pas c'est notre turbine qui ça
paraît logique non non mais ça je peux
entendre tu prends des 7
et tu as combien de pions là tu en as
deux et potentiellement
un coup n'importe où bon ça peut
toujours gagner pour les blancs mais
parce que c'est des choses
je comprends
il y a des perpettes possible des trucs
puis on prend tour des selles
on souffle
mais ouais ça fait déjà une deux trois
quatre
quatre déjà dans cette partie ouais
après parce qu'on les appelle gaffe ou
bon c'est des erreurs c'est des erreurs
puisque tu laisses faire pète tu perds
en un coup et pas prendre ces gaffe non
il y a quatre gars dans cette partie
pour l'ombre enfin on va dire trois gars
fait une faute
c'est rare ce niveau du
ouais après en plus c'est des trucs
genre le perpète je sais pas moi
j'aurais sué évidemment en partie mais
bon moi je suis pas un joueur pour titre
mondiale déjà et dit que je pense il
peut calculer tout ça après
ok après dingue oui voilà il peut faire
quoi il peut il peut trouver donc c'est
dommage par fait et après c'est possible
de mieux défendre peut-être pour ne pas
ou quoi après avoir le problème c'est
voilà c'est très compliqué de toute
façon on le sait mais
ce que j'ai déjà dit l'autre jour c'est
quand c'est un match pour le titre
mondial on s'attend qu'à un moment il y
a un truc extraordinaire de fait
enfin que ce soit pas juste des coups
évident à jouer tout le long de la
partie tu dois faire un truc spécial
pour être champion du monde quoi
peut-être le truc spécial à faire
finalement c'est pas faire de conneries
c'est déjà dur oh c'est déjà très dur
enfin c'est un jeu dur les échecs c'est
pas mais
mais qu'à un moment tu en soit sur le
cul c'est un peu comme le dessin que
l'autre jour tu vas voir bravo mais le
truc quand même c'est que c'est c'est un
truc bravo à un moment où on s'en fout
de faire bravo tu peux changer les dames
il faut faire ce que tu voulais voilà
donc en fait on voudrait un truc comme
dessin dans un moment comme là où tu
calcules ah il y a pas perfect
voilà les trucs comme ça et ça en fait
je sais pas si on a enfin je veux pas de
m'aider dans peut-être il y a eu mais je
crois peut-être qu'on l'a jamais aucun
match en fait
bah je sais pas les roches de Kasparov
oui mais bon peut-être que tu regardais
avec l'oeil d'aujourd'hui
dans la finale un truc qui te avec le
cavalier
alors on en est où il reste quatre coups
quatre coups
hier j'ai regardé toutes les parties
spécifer j'ai eu cramique les noms de
cramique avant de Carlson et du coup
la conclusion
c'est le truc c'est que maintenant on va
voir la responsaante ça biaise ça
faisait autant d'erreurs mais au moins
là
c'est ce que je pense aussi c'est juste
qu'avant comme on n'avait pas les
réponses instantanées des ordinateurs on
s'en rendait moins en compte
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il faut être
si méfiant quand tu as des joueurs qui
trouvent trop de première ligne de leur
dit oui c'est pas normal
ah mais je suis très content
minimum en fait déjà pour commencer
ça serait vraiment minimum
et j'enlèverai le truc sans délai pour
les streamers là ah mais ça c'est
honteux
parce qu'après tu as du doute sur tous
les stries enfin tu peux pas en fait ça
c'est ça moi je laisserai jamais de
passe droit sur le délai en fait c'est
trop important
là il y a combien de bah là il y a pas
de délai mais là il y a des mesures de
sécurité
donc là c'est un cas où t'es pas obligé
de mettre de délai mais dans tous les
tournois tu as pas des mesures extrêmes
moi je te foutrais du délai partout ce
serait vite vu ce serait la norme et
puis au final
donc une époque il veut ramener
peut-être le cavalier voir faire un F2
j'imagine s'il a il a l'occasion
sur sale sauve souvent il y aura un pion
on va passer mais bon mais peut-être un
petit fou ces 6 pour bien blinder
comme ça en plus avec vous c'est 6 on
défend bien décès donc on va faire dames
prends B6 et enlever le pion 1 le pion a
qui va faire la diff en fait au final
avec ce fou qui contrôle la case de
promotion
on parlait de Fisher c'est Fisher time à
neuf
enfin pas dans cette position c'est la
fameuse finale turfu contre tour
cavalierons de cheval pas du tout c'est
de l'eau de finale mais c'est le même
match mais il a un fond en F3 qui est
vissé et il se démerde pour faire un
pion à passer et il le pousse comme un
fou furieux
avec trois pions sur chaque elle
Ukraine de triangles et il faut filer le
roi
exactement à kangal qui c'est exactement
cette partie mais il t'envoie le Piona
avec un fou F3 qui avance comme ça c'est
très très peur
alors le roi H2 ouais mais il y en a
plusieurs des voyageurs
[Musique]
mais moi je la plus connue c'est je
pense les matchs de 90
c'est le match de 90 et c'est une
Espagnole zait
trop ou quatre dans ce match donc tu
pourras trouver c'est peut-être vers la
partie fin du match ou je sais pas quoi
voilà 20e partie de 90 d'après tarzelda
exactement et sinon je pense il a déjà
fait un roi H2 c'était pas une enfin je
sais plus mais alors peut-être match de
86 après moi j'ai déjà fait un tournage
de c'est un mec me fait tourner un échec
j'avais le pion H3 j'ai foutu mon range
mais là je parlais des cours parce que
pourquoi juste et c'est juste une partie
d'attaque bon très connu mais j'arrive à
toutes les pièces quoi vers le roi de
carpent
et tu t'attends je sais pas tu as plein
de coups qui vont sacrifier ou tu et en
fait il fait roi H2 c'est juste la
dernière prophylaxie pour éviter des
histoires d'échec sur la première rangée
qui pourrait sauver les Noirs etc
et
[Musique]
ok c'est quoi
je dis pas que c'est un trouvable tu
mettras des gens maintenant ils y
penseraient
mais
c'est un truc qui marque quoi voilà
c'est ça je veux dire et donc et ben
Ding là il te trouve toute la série de
coup pour essayer le perpète ou quoi on
dit waouh quel calcul enfin c'est ça que
je voulais dire dans le waouh voilà
et bien sûr je comprends que c'est très
dur enfin je moi je dis pas que c'est
simple je l'aurais je l'aurais pas vu
quoi personnellement mais
j'ai envie qu'il le voit quoi
mais t'aurais pas vu la 16e partie du
match de 86 aussi l'autre orage ok c'est
ça
j'avais 86 mais je sais plus quelle
partie ouais c'est impressionnant à
chaque fois
on se demande qui est grand maître ici
votre pronostic sur la victoire finale
je pense quand même que il va à
l'emporter
dingue
je sais pas c'est trop dur de se
prononcer
c'est hyper dur quoi
en fait le problème c'est que chaque
fois j'ai un
[Musique]
bon alors c'est
que je dois dire que c'est un truc j'ai
10 ans regardez quoi que peut-être c'est
une menace donc
[Musique]
une nouvelle fois non mais en fait avec
les Noirs tu es tellement mal que tu as
envie de faire un truc et après je sais
pas bon je vois pas pourquoi c'est 00 il
peut tout se passer quoi mais je
penserai être mieux avec les blancs mais
je suis rien parce qu'en fait là j'en ai
marre mais qu'est-ce que je fais
exception j'avance pas en fait oui mais
c'est en fait je regarde la position
puis en fait le fouger de Emma
depuis longtemps
pourquoi pas possessif
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui
c'est quoi le problème de ça
c'est le mental
ce que tu as le foot de cave en quelque
sorte
c'est trop fort et qui attaque c'est
trop fort
en fait que c'est un craquage mental bah
voilà
l'énigme ça se voit direct
ça c'est incroyable
franchement là tu le vois qui peut te
faire je sais pas trop quoi penser je
mais je me dis
[Musique]
et en plus là il est pire que tout parce
que le fond extra tu le fais vraiment
fermer
on reprend des scènes de me prendre des
6 qui te fait F5 tu te plantes en dessin
qui tu pousses quand même tu pousses là
quand même
là Fab bon c'est peut-être un tournoi du
match pour le coup là
ça sera pas faim il y aura qu'un point
d'écart mais je l'imagine mal perdre
quand même cette partie mais oui mais
mentalement ça fait mal ça fait mal
parce que ça fait deux d'affilés
au moment c'était obligé de prendre avec
la tour alors bon c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait défoncer 6 mais à un moment là
tu donnes un option au passé qui fonce
ah tu avais un pion F2 qui a disparu
en fait mais c'est dramatique quoi que
ce soit le meilleur quoi
A4 puis je sais pas ok ça j'en sais rien
c'est chaud quoi
[Musique]
dans cette partie là il y a quand même
beaucoup de gaffe je suis désolé mais
je veux bien que la position soit hyper
compliqué ou quoi mais là ça en fait
beaucoup sur une partie quand même non
mais là
très franchement c'est beaucoup
plus le fou il va vraiment devenir nul
non mais tu peux vraiment être là tu te
prends l'option
mais le foot je sais pas ce qu'il vient
de se faire enfermer de se faire bloquer
le fou
c'est pénible quoi ça enfin c'est
pénible
ça va c'est une pièce de plus et bon tu
peux peut-être la rendre et je sais pas
quoi donc je penserai pas perdre les
blancs mais j'ai du mal maintenant sur
le coup je me suis dit bon ok peut-être
ça tient pas je vais essayer de pousser
là mais en fait juste dans un deuxième
temps je me suis dit mais en fait il
fait quoi ce fou quoi
il y a deux heures que on pouvait
vouloir rendre la pièce pour enfermer le
fou donc c'est pas quelque chose de dur
après avoir si genre là ce qu'on peut en
couple comme tour des deux dans le de
toute façon on va la voir ce truc là
alors attends
peut-être plus malin
je veux f55
en tout cas
[Musique]
faut garder le four je sais pas où
manger deux machin
[Musique]
de faire 4 4 de revenir là ça peut plier
le match quoi
[Musique]
cible là ça c'est
ça c'est grave
c'est vraiment dur normal le perpète
normal tu peux quand même le trouver en
match championnat du monde
et bon ça par contre c'est OK enfin même
si toi non
je sors de la partie je suis
et puis quand tu accumul ça avec la
partie précédente tu perds autant tu te
dis bon
ça va pas du tout
[Musique]
c'est le même scénario
non mais ok mais ça j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi on serait mieux
non mais du coup enfin si on veut jouer
pour nul on garde le fou on va pas le
donner pour le donner il va faire prise
on va prendre il va faire F5 on met la
tour en deux on fait à 4 je sais pas
quoi et là il a du mal à avancer avec
F4 il peut pas 3 il ouvre notre fou j'ai
5 fois c'est dangereux tu as fait BF5
donc là ça va je me sens pas trop trop
en danger mais nul oui enfin c'est
probable nul en fait du coup je fais un
statu quo quoi
mais si je veux faire nul il faut j'ai
pas envie de le sacrifier direct quoi
ça va il y a un coup il y a deux coups
tu te rappelles ce qu'il a fait la
dernière fois
a suffi
suffit après la dame prend ici c'est
facile il en restera un seul à jouer
le fou
et je suis un peu je suis déçu parce que
c'est
on était tellement proche d'avoir un
bunker absolu ce match et là ça peut un
peu se jouer au mental mais finalement
comme le match précédent
c'était aussi au mental c'était un peu
le même type de scénario dans l'autre
sens avec une époque qui sur les six
premières parties en fait jouer un peu
mieux que mainus oui et puis le jour où
made in Gossi par un tout petit sur le
jeu mise à part mentalement quand il a
craqué sur le Game 6 en début de match
bon la pression du début de match on
peut importe mais après il a quand même
sembler légèrement plus fort jusqu'à la
partie précédente où il craque alors
qu'il doit pas craquer il est mieux et
là c'est là il doit gagner il craque en
fait au mental aux échecs enfin bref ça
se joue au nerf mais tu le dis souvent
toi Fab les parties longues c'est c'est
un jeu de nerf oui
bah tu as beaucoup plus de tension à
retenir beaucoup plus longtemps et c'est
des énormes différences par rapport au
bled et au rapide
mais c'est pour moi la différence
principale en fait parce que
[Musique]
c'est
pas toujours le meilleur joueur
intrinsèquement qui qui sera le plus
fort quoi
pour deux ok
très bien enfin il va y avoir a priori
F5
peut-être que tu reprends des 7 d'abord
et jouable aussi je pense c'est pareil
[Musique]
tu peux plus arrêter le jeu
ok avec les Noirs dernière fois ça
allait
demain je joue et je chante mes chances
avec les Blancs il y a rien de si grave
d'être mené d'un point mais voilà
occasion raté
on n'aime pas gâcher des munitions sur
ton image comme ça
et souvent c'est très mauvais signe
d'abord bouger le fou
et de me prendre des sacs maintenant
enfin oui il faut G2 de me prendre
c'est pas ou
ok ok si on MB6 dmd7 tourgers
AB3
[Musique]
hyper compliqué ouais mais ok enfin je
me dis que peut-être on est passé donc
c'était quoi c'était d'imbécile
dans le sens où il reste que 4 minutes
donc il va jouer pour les spectateurs
[Musique]
ou quoi moi je te dis qu'il est là il
impose enfin c'est fini en fait mais
pourquoi taureau
à Fab nous on a ce même défaut que Ding
oui etc
il pense à ce qu'il a raté dans cette
partie pense
ce qui s'est passé avant si il compte
c'est maintenant le moment présent quoi
c'est la position que tu as sous les
yeux et les bons quatres maintenant
ouais je pense que le match est terminé
ici Fab il est en train de tuer le match
je l'ai laissé peut-être encore de
gagner ou pas aucune lucidité là non
mais bon
il peut il peut il peut envoyer autre
chose là
le problème
il peut
est-ce que ça serait complètement
perdant après je suis pas sûr mais le
devient dur dur dur la partie
je pense qu'il est capable je pense
qu'il est capable de tout Fab
IEN il a craqué mais on a tellement de
fois été dans cette situation enfin toi
à moi tu es devant l'échiquier mais en
retard c'est bizarre on a l'impression
que tu es un poisson derrière une vitre
d'aquarium quoi tu vois rien en fait
c'est fini tu étais enterré c'est
horrible comme sensation j'ai mal pour
lui en réalité ça m'arrivait trop
souvent ce truc là c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles j'ai arrêté de jouer
d'ailleurs
tu voulais peut-être un poisson
bah si c'est pour faire ça c'est c'est
quand ça t'arrive c'est trop écœurant
quoi
mais du coup tu es parti on l'a même
qualité qu'un Blitz en fait quand tu
peux enfin quand tu fais ça parce que tu
fais des gaffes que tu aurais même pas
fait envie tu te mets en PLS
système nerveux qui impose et ouais
c'est horrible la preuve c'est que tu
fais même bien parce que j'ai
l'impression que tu t'auto mais c'est ta
main qui joue contre toi
tes réflexes tu les perds pas ils sont
toujours au fond de toi
mais normalement tu te remets quand même
quand tu récupères du temps tu peux
repartir se mettre de l'eau
mais il peut cliquer de la merde il peut
cliquer une merde liquide là il peut
refuser la ligne 1 la ligne 2 et aller
jouer un coup de merde ah mais tu le
vois arriver
allez je joue juste le coup normal tu
t'en fous
tu fais un coup normal et tu vas tu vas
tu vas récupérer mais j'ai peur qu'il
tombe en fait mais non non il a pas
tombé
mais j'ai peur moi que au dernier moment
il panique et qui joue le coup numéro 10
parce que
je joue un truc joue
oh
bon
qui nous inquiète un peu mais il a joué
avant de tomber mais lève-toi maintenant
par toi de là on aurait plus de chiquer
quoi va reprendre tes esprits
là c'est un jeu de merde
va te reposer un petit peu va souffler
[Musique]
dans un coussin tu cries là
va défoncer la salle de repos quoi il y
en a des coussins dedans
c'est pas possible ouais c'est terrible
mais bon ok du coup on a vraiment la
digue j'espère qu'il revient pas un
quart d'heure
il me laisse les chiquer bien vide il
regarde pas l'écran non plus éteins tes
télé fais autre chose fais autre chose
alors qu'il fait une partie de merde
[Rires]
ça c'est un truc cruel aux échecs
mais tu fais un coup de pied et tu perds
ou tu gagnes pas comme là
il prend de la tour pas de la dame et
peut-être on va avoir une ultra rapide
avec tomber cette torse et ça du coup
parce qu'on regarde tout à l'heure là
quand même enfin je sais pas
je crois pas que tu as envie de donner
le fou
et c'est orbaisselle donc c'est ça
tellement dire qu'il peut le faire alors
attention les gars c'est il faut quand
même très très bien enfin je sais pas si
vous imaginez mais ils ont écrasé les
candidats quand même les deux enfin
surtout Yann depuis deux fois donc
ouais enfin c'est là aujourd'hui il a
fait une mauvaise partie mais bon enfin
c'est la tension qui est tellement
grande que ça fait faire n'importe quoi
mais attention c'est
vous les remettez aux candidats les deux
ils refont mal à tous les autres je sais
pas comment dire
faut pas les prendre pour des ballons
non plus quoi
quand même rappeler deux trois bases
quoi
ça joue en dessous des attentes
je sais pas en fait
le mieux jouer les gens non il y a
beaucoup de parties c'est long il y a de
la pression il y a beaucoup de
préparation c'est dur et ça change ta
vie enfin tu as toujours pour l'histoire
quand même
[Musique]
c'est pas le tournoi
même les droits je respecte
c'est du pipi de chat comparé quoi
et pourtant je respecte c'est vraiment
un beau tournoi et c'est chaud d'aller
gagner quoi mais je veux dire
c'est match là c'est quelque chose en
plus que mon Enjou plus maintenant les
mecs ils découvrent ça ils sont ils sont
tremblants
donc c'est dur
prête à certains qui arrivent à se
vraiment je veux des matchs de ouf genre
cramique
son prémage de championnats du monde
[Musique]
que tu gagnes
son compte c'est irréel d'avoir un petit
peu de sécurité dans tout ce que tu fais
pour c'est le match mais bon après donc
ça c'est fou mais bon je
c'est tellement naïf
ces trucs
bah ouais bon au moins pas perdre
mais bon il s'est pas assez baladé à mon
goût mais au moins il est de retour
si jamais on peut avoir une répète pour
lui c'est pas si mal mais ça va
normalement il va fouger d'eux il y a
pas de grand danger non je suis fou
[Musique]
oui mais quoi en fait comment je peux
vas-y bouge madame qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils font là en fait
un truc comme ça
mais
[Musique]
oui allez c'est un peu faire gaffe
des prépas c'est juste ils ont certaines
des lignes sur des comptes publics comme
des cons ouais enfin c'est certaines 70
quoi voilà le problème c'est qu'il y a
eu H3 et il y a aujourd'hui donc c'est
en plus c'est pas les trucs que tu
comptes peut-être pas jouer du tout et
puis en plus on peut te diriger qu'on
peut voir où talik et puis t'amener
enfin on peut t'amener sur un délic ça
suffit en fait
non mais c'est assez grave pour eux
c'est comme dit Maxime le seul détail
qu'on sait pas à 100% c'est ce n'est pas
été au courant des comptes
mais c'est 80% bah ouais en fait c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il était si bien
préparé que si il avait
je pense hein ce qu'il avait loin comme
disait Vlad c'était dur
oui
on parle au tout début
là en fait ça fait peur que j'ai 5 en
fait lui s'en Fouta
tu fais H6 tu te prends H4 enfin
normalement tu es tu as rien compris
qu'avec les noirs et tu prends et il se
trouve que c'est pas si grave mais en
fait là je serai pas étonné qui est
maths
pour les blancs je veux bien croire quoi
bon il se trouve que non mais ouais du
coup
il est rentré la dent de gaieté de cœur
après peu importe il a décapité de
calcul que j'ai pas donc il peut
peut-être trouver comprendre mais bon
ils ont pu trouver avec la première
partie en fait
mets-moi après le truc qui me fait
penser que non c'est que pourquoi ils
auraient attendu aussi longtemps pour
reviser un truc parce que le H3 c'était
il y a quand même un certain moment
mais vu quoi d'autre le système de
Londres
[Musique]
on pourra pas savoir de toute façon on
peut rien savoir
oui ils vont rien dire peut-être après
le match Nico va dire oui bon en fait
je savais pour le lit pour le lit depuis
longtemps ou quoi mais
de toute façon ça joue pas là-dessus
aujourd'hui
non non aujourd'hui ça se joue pas
dessus parce que
parce que toute façon une fois que tout
ça a été fait il a eu la position
gagnante
[Musique]
mais après moi je sais pas si une époque
était si près ou quoi enfin
parce que je trouve qu'il l'a pas bien
joué la partie
en tout cas c'est fou cette histoire
incroyable
que tu retrouves pas même quelques
échelons en dessous de la compétition
que moi déjà j'ai peur de ça et je le
fais pas
[Musique]
mais bon moi tu vas pas le championnat
du monde donc
mais déjà oui du coup
[Musique]
non mais c'est dommage enfin je veux
dire si quitte à faire des matchs
d'entraînement fait en vrai quoi
déjà en temps normal non mais la tu as
sûrement un budget pour ton champion du
monde ou quoi ça va tu peux
et franchement ouais tu comptes anonyme
ou d'autres plateformes de jeux moins
connus ou tu fais un truc partage
d'écran enfin tu fais un truc on va pas
te hacker quoi
alors ça c'est pas un coup qu'on a
regardé
les parties seront pas sauvegardées rien
enfin je vais rester dans c'est d'une
bêtise et ça rentre en fait
tout ça pour sauvegarder plus facilement
les parties j'imagine oui mais c'est
débile
quand tu as fini au pire tu fais une
capture écran tu as un mec qui note
n'importe quoi enfin tu me souviens de
tes parties aussi au cas où enfin ça va
on va y arriver quoi
c'est le facteur belge
en anonyme tu peux télécharger ça sent
l'expérimente l'expérience que oui
mais c'est fou d'avoir fait ça en fait
non mais c'est dramatique c'est
en plus ils ont été deux à le faire quoi
[Musique]
la personne s'est posé la question et
plus peut-être enfin probablement qu'il
y avait 3e personne donc qui était au
courant qu'ils allaient jouer machin et
qui ont dû recevoir les fichiers et là
tu vois que c'est pas Anonymus contre
Anonymous c'est
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est le veau contre contre
l'autre et puis voilà quoi tout à
l'heure c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
avoir que des grands maîtres dans ton
équipe il faut avoir un compte
un grand maître comme moi peut-être
pour éviter c'est trop
bien
c'était le frère de nepo
la vengeance d'une personne entourage de
Digne qui a dit que c'est parti mais non
ils l'ont fait eux-mêmes de getter de
cœur en fait les parties c'est pas
vraiment même pas un lit qu'en fait je
peux pas appeler ça unique c'est même
pas un lit en vrai on appelle ça vite
mais c'est pas un livre pas sécurisé
quoi enfin je sais pas quoi dire c'est
comme si tu as ta boîte mail et que et
que tu avais décidé sur Internet
d'écrire ton mot de passe c'est même pas
un lit en fait quelqu'un qui t'a arc ou
quoi que ce soit c'est juste tu es con
en fait
mais en fait juste pour ça qu'il
m'arrive de pas gagner maintenant mais
tu es trop con en fait non mais je dis
un peu crûment mais
c'est trop en fait d'être aussi con
mais c'est fou quoi
du coup ça a rien à voir avec les échecs
quoi c'est juste autre chose mais c'est
tu te prépares pour le truc ou tout est
ultra secret et toi tu
tu m'étais prépa en libre accès sur
Internet quoi en gros voilà
c'est peut-être la prépa d'un autre
joueur il a piqué deux lignes ouais non
en fait non apparemment non
elle est partie d'entraînement les
comptes ils sont créés en février en
fait il y a trop de trucs qui font que
non tout coïncide vous recevez
c'est quoi déjà la phrase quand le
complot est possible la bêtise il faut
toujours favoriser l'hypothèque de la
bêtise là je crois vraiment que c'est de
la bêtise pure et du en fait
c'est ce qui rend le truc c'est
incroyable
alors c'était nettement moins grave
c'était quand même chiant pour lui en
fait il a eu un reportage je suis plus
une équipe télé quoi qui était venue le
filmer et en fait à un moment tu vois
son écran de chez base et
donc tu vois peut-être le nom des
fichiers ou je sais pas quoi où c'était
écrit pétrole calife6 parce que il y
avait un plan qui est 17 qui est 6 il le
ramenait comme ça dans une ligne ou quoi
donc ça peut donner des indices mais tu
avais pas le contenu
donc c'est déjà chiant enfin c'est déjà
dommage d'avoir fait ça mais
[Musique]
moins grave
c'était une base de données
petite connerie quand même non non mais
déjà à l'époque on avait dit que c'était
très très cool
et puis c'est pas mal enfin ouais mais
ça du coup pas tellement porté à
conséquence peut-être aussi parce qu'il
se trouve la ligne était tellement
blindée car le ça n'est même pas essayé
d'aller voir dedans mais du coup il
aurait pu avoir une petite idée savoir
que athée va peut-être faire ça et du
coup je le plante je sais pas en fait
mais
donc bref
mais du coup ça a donné envie d'aller
voir les prépas pour les jouets quoi
franchement ouais non mais des idées en
tout cas
bon H3 j'ai quand même pas envie de le
jouer moi je sais pas je sens pas le
coup tu vois
trop fin pour moi
mais bon tu donnes la direction tu
donnes beaucoup tu donnes beaucoup
d'informations qui permettent de faire
viser en fait suffisamment evidemment
c'est pas tout le fichier c'est que des
parties qu'il a joué en prévision de ça
mais
c'est déjà trop quoi
c'est déjà beaucoup
mais c'était vraiment lui les
historiques auraient déjà été supprimés
mais comment tuer les supprimer en fait
parce que tu peux plus en fait tu es sur
les chaises c'est comme par exemple tu
as un compte sur les chaises c'est que
tu es triché sur les chaises
du coup quand les gens ils tapent ton
prénom et ton nom si jamais tu avais été
assez bête pour mettre ton prénom et ton
nom ben il voit tes que tu as triché
quoi
admettons mais tu peux plus le supprimer
et là c'est pareil en fait
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
il est parti elles sont sauvegardées
dans la base de données
et donc bon
là c'est déjà fini c'est fini même si il
supprime maintenant il y a trop de monde
qui
[Musique]
a été téléchargé et qui sait
voilà juste pour revenir donc la partie
sur ce qui se passe directement sur les
chéquiers bon
ordi nous donne déjà les trois premières
lignes à 0-0 donc basiquement des
répétitions
je sais pas si une époque plus en fait
on a bien parlé d'élite
[Musique]
mais il doit chercher plus ouais mais je
vois pas comment il peut y avoir tout à
l'heure ce qu'on a analysé ça me
montrait bien que
non
tu vas te rebaissette moi je pensais
dans ma F4 et
des 7 ou d'un 8 pour éviter
mais bon
c'est dans ma cadre de l'autre côté
non je pense c'est nul forcer et
peut-être qu'il a un peu de bol
dingue
il était peut-être pas en état
ouais marrant qu'il se soit fait ban de
chasse comme qui a repéré la marque
bonne job de la team anti triche quand
même
je vais trop bien
ils ont recréé des comptes sur Lydia
soit avec les mêmes pseudos derrière du
coup non mais ils ont c'est beaucoup
trop je sais pas comment dire mais c'est
beaucoup trop ce qu'ils ont fait en fait
c'est beaucoup trop con
non non il a pas triché
ils ont les pseudos de tout le monde et
tu donnes ton identité et en fait quand
tu as des gens qui donnent pas leur
identité et que ça joue à 2800 et l'eau
il se disent enfin ils doivent même pas
pensé que Céline quoi ils se disent oui
bon bah c'est des mecs qui trichent quoi
et voilà c'est des amateurs qui et c'est
tout
faire les stages au Pakistan
les informations sont bien gardées
secret de Baki ne quitte jamais le pays
bon ça va ça va terminer
on sait pas quand mais oui donc la
prochaine fois on a dépassé le 40e et ça
a terminé par a priori
[Musique]
c'est tellement le
coup de marteau sur la tête pour dire
entre la partie complètement ratée celle
d'avant
ouais c'est problème là qui vont être
supplémentaires à gérer
il va falloir un miracle maintenant pour
bah faudrait que par chance pour lui il
est tout un pendu répertoire qui n'est
pas été là-dessus c'est pas pourquoi
enfin pour grâce
[Musique]
que j'arrive à regarder E4 aussi qu'il
en est jamais blitzer sur ce compte ou
tu vois enfin du coup il change tout
enfin un truc comme ça quoi c'est après
donc c'était peut-être sa prépa au blanc
si je jouais au 4
mais pas c'est plus pétrole non
il voulait faire un peu de la berlinoise
j'en sais rien
t'as pas le choix en fait peut-être
c'est le seul match de champion du monde
que tu feras de ta vie
[Musique]
ce qui est fait effet enfin c'est con
mais c'est fait enfin
ce que je te dise
tu peux dire ouais ben dans le jeu
regarde tu le domines tu es plus fort
ça devait pas arriver tu aurais mieux
mais que ça n'arrive pas
[Musique]
est-ce que tu peux te battre quoi et
c'est ça qu'il faut faire c'est tout
et puis encore une fois vraiment dans le
jeu
dans le jeu il y a rien à envier et
après c'est chiant c'est craquage
manteau effectivement
ça pour le coup
du coup tu balances c'est ça
ouais
du gain du match il va craquer mais j'ai
pas l'impression en fait
non enfin
il l'a pas fait
il a su voilà aujourd'hui il a quand
même fait une très mauvaise partie il a
mal joué mais je suis pas sur ça par
craquage c'est que la position était
compliqué qu'il a pas été à la hauteur
de la tâche mais je suis pas sûr que ce
soit mental
c'est juste que
mais
on verra en fait on n'en sais rien on a
deux joueurs on a nos interrogations sur
leur manière de gérer pour l'instant
Ding elle a un peu plus touché quoi en
tout cas clairement que
qui gère pas mal mais ça peut empêcher
que digne de partir aujourd'hui il
aurait dû gagner il a vraiment eu les
cartes pour
ok la raté
mais donc j'ai vraiment du mal moi à
m'avancer quand on m'a demandé avant le
match j'avais pensé que une époque
serait favori nettement je sais pas mais
genre 60-40 ou un truc comme ça quoi
plutôt époque mais après quelques rondes
je savais plus quoi dire oui bon j'en
sais rien 55 ans donc voilà je vais pas
faire la girouette au fur et à mesure
des parties à dire au niveau de la
gagner c'est sûr
je sais pas c'est très équilibré
mais bon c'est sûr que là le scénario
depuis deux trois jours laisse une
tendance
mais bon il y a rien de faire il y a pas
de break quoi
[Musique]
il y a un point d'éclair seulement
le système de Londres
[Musique]
mais du coup bah voilà là c'est un peu
c'est un peu ça le Link qui lui est
arrivé
c'est beau quand même comme manière de
gagner sur la langue
il aurait su il aurait tiré la langue en
faisant l'inverse
mais le haut niveau ça je suis toujours
sur des détails et c'est juste pour dire
que là entre c'est entre des Caraïbes ça
se jouait en tirage de langue sur des
services ils sont quand les niveaux sont
proches ça joue à rien
mais bon bravo
parce que personne d'autre on est rendu
compte dans tous les autres personnes
souviens un gros craquage Championnat du
Monde bah le dernier match
après bon on va essayer de la remonter
dans le temps Carlson Carolina y a pas
eu car il n'y a pas eu un an de non non
on les quoi jouer la carroscane mais
non plus
mais bon
voilà qu'est-ce que je crois pas les
cartes peuvent cassent pas off ça jouait
car peuvent corseneuil
ah franchement
du mal à dire
sur les derniers matchs
mais pas sur une partie je veux dire des
fois
mais comme bon son champion du monde de
n'importe où tu peux faire une gaffe
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
tu peux
nous avons Brunstein la dernière partie
qui par contre pas de Viny qui fait pas
une grande partie
tu joues pour nul tu peux faire une
gaffe mille fois
tu peux faire 1000 gaffe une fois mais
tu peux pas faire 1000 gaffe mille fois
en fait
on doit faire on n'a pas le choix Notre
Dame attaqué notre fou aussi donc pas
parce que tout le monde te reprend et on
s'attend à sacrifice il est pas obligé
mais bon tu as envie c'est que les trois
pions ils sont trop fort
S
mais
[Musique]
ça c'est possible il faut pas prendre le
fou
et
contrairement au roi blanc mais donc
bouffe tour des deux je sais pas déjà
faut prendre la tour
je préfère l'autre je préfère l'autre
aussi mais elle doit être nulle aussi
alors question
organisationnel ce qu'on a encore une
pause à faire ou pas spécialement toutes
les pubs ont été passées
bah je sais pas moi
je crois que on a
je peux pas te dire
on peut faire une pause pour faire une
pause aussi
[Musique]
ça risque de pas forcément trop s'animer
mais bon alors de me prendre ici
est-ce que tu me parlerais pas du
nouveau livre que tu as écrit Fab qu'on
a fait ensemble
alors ce petit cahier d'entraînement
non mais on est très content de du livre
l'ivresse bleu comme vous voulez c'est
80 pages
donc c'est pas un livre énorme mais il y
a quand même je crois 286 exercices
dedans
il y a 23 quiz il y a des mots mêlés il
y a des des trucs à relier
voilà donc c'est pas mal un point de vue
culture générale échec
des exercices donc par thème voilà genre
etc
il y a un dernier chapitre un peu plus
dur
en mode on vous dit pas ce que devait
chercher débrouillez-vous et voilà donc
sympathique à lire joli parce que coloré
en couleur déjà
de 1000 à 1800 hello je dirais même de
débutants jusqu'à 1800
et
puis bon on essaie de bien le faire le
mieux possible quoi après voilà on
espère que ça vous plaira mais pour la
modique somme de 10 euros quand même un
peu moins 9,90
je mets le lien dans le chat important
mais je pense va être n'importe qui peut
le lire c'est souvent en fait les
derniers exercices des chapitres sont un
peu poussés
individuellement mais c'est un bon
exercice entraînement tactique il peut
très bien aller avec les autres aussi
mais je pense qu'une continuité en terme
de niveau c'est pas
[Musique]
bon là ça arrive dans la position qu'on
donnait ça va probablement faire nul
mais peut-être pas vite parce que mais
il faut encore être précis de part et
d'autre
tout ça pour moins de 10 balles 9,90
du livre débutant jusqu'à 1800 et l'eau
même 2000 chaises comme je dirais parce
que j'ai fait des tests hier en montrant
une page et déjà elle est une étoile les
1500 litchi 1500 chscom
issu
entre 30 secondes et une minute alors
imagine ça peut jusqu'à 3 étoiles et
qu'il y ait des trois étoiles plus bon
ils sont à trois étoiles mais
bref six ce qu'on arrive à faire une
contre l'ordi ben pas sûr
la réponse on y arriverait mais pas tout
le temps
je me barre par là pour pas me faire cut
à la fin faites moi je partirai pour une
défense comme ça
je me laisserai pousser la gueule pour
essayer d'aller faire ça donc peut-être
que quand j'arrive là il fait tomber
parce qu'il est malin il te ferme
aura 5 tours B3
je commence à harceler un peu
du coup tu passes et bon bah là et ça
fait nul ouais donc je pense que ça
c'est une variante logique pour terminer
la partie
de jouer aucune des prépas sur des
comptes qui ont des ouvertures communes
avec mes comptes quand même c'est
vraiment une dinguerie ah bah ouais mais
bon c'était t'avais une préparation
quand même
c'est pas pour rien qu'on a gagné quand
même
parce que l'adversaire en finale est un
à l'époque il était un petit peu plus
fort que Sardoche mais j'y suis enfin
que c'était
un peu plus fort que ça à l'époque
maintenant sarde le batterie assez assez
facilement à mon avis mais au moment où
il y a eu la finale du poker il était un
tout petit peu en dessous
mais ça avait gagné quand même les
prépas étaient bonnes et oui on avait
été on avait fait très attention on
avait réussi à piéger Hikaru et
c'était contre excusé je pense
mais oui on faisait très attention à
justement à ça mais c'est pour ça que
c'est si étonnant parce que ouais c'est
vrai que ça j'avais j'avais oublié ce
truc là mais c'est vrai que même
on avait déjà fait gaffe
non mais c'est normal enfin oui enfin
c'est j'arrive pas à comprendre du coup
Ding fait ça mais bon
je pense c'était le match contre excusé
il était tellement dégoûté et Carouge
sur le live que je me rappelle de sarde
qui fait cavalier 5 où est-ce qu'on F4
un machin et je rappelle les Caro il
fait genre c'est n'importe quoi et puis
trois quoi
après il fait sa petite amie très malin
ok il va juste faire il avait compris le
truc et il se fait complètement Kiko F4
il était pas bien après et sur le coup
et après
c'est un beau pot de Champex
[Musique]
c'est qu'ils te font ça avec tout c'est
quand il y a un truc qui marche il te le
bon pain dans la gueule après du coup tu
voilà
mais si en fait c'était pas mais non
c'est comme ça
bon alors la pause
lors de la pause pourquoi pas
être sûr allez ça marche à tout de suite
on reviendra petite dizaine de minutes
j'imagine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais donc nul
bonne nulle pour Nevo au final c'est
l'huile gagnante de cette journée
mais donc bon il reste à portée de tir
il y a que un point d'écart et des gens
on va voir demain comment ça se passe et
pour la suite du match donc demain il va
jouer pour essayer de faire le break
donc on
se retrouve demain à 11h et puis on vous
fait le petit résumé bientôt merci à
tous d'avoir suivi et à demain 11h pour
la suite du tournoi ciao ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]